As chair of Division III of the House Finance Committee, I find that due to the state of emergency declared, and we're recording, aren't we, Mr.
Ripple?
Yeah, okay.
Declared by the governor's emergency order number 12 pursuant to Executive Order 2020-04 is extended.
This public body is authorized to meet electronically.
Please note that there is no physical location to observe and listen contemporaneously to this meeting, which was authorized pursuant to the governor's emergency order.
However, in accordance with the emergency order, I'm confirming that we are providing public access to the meeting by telephone with additional access possibilities by video or other electronic means.
We're using Zoom video webinar for this remote meeting.
All members of the committee and staff of state agency with agenda items have the ability to communicate contemporaneously during this meeting through this platform and the public has access to contemporaneously watch and or listen to the meeting on Zoom or phone following the direction and links provided in the House calendar.
And it's been in the House calendar since calendar eight through the present, and they're all online at the GenCourt website.
And in that calendar, we've previously given notice to the public of the necessary information for accessing the meeting telephonically.
Instructions are also in the House calendar.
However, if anyone's having troubles accessing this by phone or by video, they should email the LBA underscore fiscal, F-I-S-C-A-L at leg, L-E-G dot state dot N-H dot U-S.
And if nobody, if we have a problem with the public accessing it and know about it, we'll go ahead and adjourn and reschedule.
If we take any votes today, and I don't anticipate any, it'll be by roll call vote.
So let's go ahead and, representative or if you have your hand up now, did you mean to say something now before roll call?
Yes, I want to let you know the representative Weiler told us yesterday that he would be here today, but he'll be late.
Okay, so representative Bean, would you go ahead and take attendance?
And then as we go through, if each member would just state their physical location and the presence of others, we need that for the right to know requirements.
Good morning, all.
Representative Walner.
Representative Walner is here.
I'm in Concord in my home and my husband is in the house with me.
Representative Nordgren.
Representative Nordgren, I'm here in my dining room, which appears to be my office now, and I'm alone.
Representative Rogers.
Representative Rogers, I'm in Concord, New Hampshire in my apartment with my dog, Romeo.
Representative Orr.
Present, home alone in my home office.
Representative Edwards.
I'm in Auburn in my home office.
And I have family and dogs in the house, but they're unlikely to come in.
Representative Weiler is obviously missing temporarily.
I'm Representative Bean.
I'm in Guilford in my house, and I'm here alone.
All right.
Well, thank you for that.
Good morning, everyone.
We have, I think it's an interesting day today.
One, because the topic of the morning in public health is interesting in light of COVID and what they've done and listening to what they need to be able to do post-pandemic.
And then this afternoon, we've got some invited guests coming in to talk to us about particular aspects of the budget.
So I think it's going to be an interesting day, but it's really up to Ms.
Tilley to make it interesting.
So we'll go ahead and get started when you're ready, Mr.
Ripple.
Yep, I think everybody's in and you're good to go.
Good morning, everyone.
So I'm going to turn it right over to Lisa, the Director of Public Health, and Patricia Talley, the Deputy Director of Public Health.
I just wanted to mention that as far as today goes, when we get to the accounting units, it is about 90 pages of the budget book that we'll be going through today, just to give you a little preview to that.
The way that public health is doing their presentation is they are going through their entire division and then we will hit all of the accounting units for the entire division.
So just to make you aware, I won't be jumping in in the middle of this presentation.
Okay, so because the accounting units, the details are going to take so much time, I would just ask the presenters, we were provided this slide deck in advance, assume we've looked at it, assume that we generally know what's been going on with COVID, and try to keep moving.
All right, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm terribly sorry.
You're good to go.
Good to go.
Go ahead, Lisa.
Great.
So good morning, Representative Edwards and members of the Division III Finance Committee.
We're very pleased today to present the work of the Division of Public Health Services.
The presenters for this particular presentation are myself as the Director of the Division of Public Health Services.
The presenters for this particular presentation are myself as the director of the division, Patricia Tilly, or Tricia, is the deputy director of the division, and Shelley Swanson, Rochelle Swanson, is the finance director, and will be doing this presentation.
And Representative Edwards, I'm not sure that you have seen this particular presentation before, and we apologize for not getting it to you sooner than this moment.
So please bear with us.
So Mr.
Ripple sent me something last night.
Sent us also.
Oh, okay.
Oh, all right.
Okay, that's great.
We're a 24 by seven committee at this point.
So 20, yes, I know.
I, yes, I'm sure that you are.
So today's agenda is going to include outcomes in the overview of the work that we do, key program services and our population served, delivery system accomplishments, key challenges, financial summary, and prioritized needs.
So we're going to move to the next slide.
So we are a relatively large bureau.
We have nine bureaus, 249 staff, 70 accounting units.
So we have many programs.
Much of our work is done out of contracts with agencies out in the community.
So we have 344 current contracts, which is quite a few and keeps us very busy.
55% of our budget are federal funds, such as CDC or the Health Resources Services Administration, just to name a few.
Only 16% of our total budget are general funds, so we do not rely heavily on general funds.
And 29% of our budget is other funds, such as fees, pharmaceutical rebates, the New Hampshire Vaccine Association, to name a few.
Although we focus on...
Yes, Representative?
So as questions come up, I'll be raising my hand.
Okay.
So a question I just started asking in the last 24 hours when it comes to staff is, it'd be great if you could break that down for how many personnel are authorized as permanent and as unclassified, the total 249 at the end of the FY21 budget.
And then if you could just summarize for us what you're expected that to be at the end of FY23 and the total of how many you have on hand.
So one question we keep asking is about vacancy rates.
And so out of that 249, if you've got a 20% vacancy rate or whatever it is, we'd like to see what your current headcount is.
You don't need to do all that right now, but I'm just letting you know that that's the kind of stuff we're also looking at.
We'll certainly get that information to you, Representative Edwards, if not today.
We'll follow up with any questions that are asked today that we're unable to answer momentarily at the moment.
You weren't prepared for that question, so I'm not expecting it today.
Okay, thank you.
So as I had started to mention that although we focus on the most vulnerable populations in the state of New Hampshire, which are varied relative to the subject matter, we do serve and cover all 1.36 million of the citizens within the state of New Hampshire.
So if you could go to the next slide.
So, you know, like you, we have had a very challenging year and our focus really has been on the response for COVID.
We have put the majority of the work that we're doing on COVID on the public dashboard.
So you can see that every day.
And I feel confident that all of you have been on the dashboard.
And you will see recently we added a vaccine dashboard as well.
So you can monitor how much vaccine has been administered and is available to us in the state of New Hampshire.
But this particular slide is showing the number of cases that we had yesterday and the average cases per day and the seven-day average.
But we have investigated and monitored close contacts for over 76,000 individuals, almost 77,000 individuals, which is pretty unbelievable.
We had a low case count of about seven in July, but we had well over 1,000 cases in December and January.
And of course, over the last number of weeks, our case counts have dramatically reduced.
We are on the road to recovery, including not only have our case counts reduced, but also hospitalizations and death, which I know that you agree is, you know, makes us very, very happy.
And we believe that we are on the road to recovery.
So the next slide is our vaccination slide.
And it shows you how many doses, which is the vaccination slide.
And it shows you how many doses, which is the gray line, that have been administered.
And then the blue line is how many individuals are fully vaccinated.
So you can see that each day, of course, this will improve as we're vaccinating thousands of individuals per day.
What's your projection, Ms.
Morris, on when the vaccination program will have hit sort of a maturity point to where we're not tracking population stats on a daily basis and this just fades back into the routine vaccination efforts?
Well, of course, it will depend upon the volume of vaccine that we're able to get into the state.
It is increasing every single week, so we're very pleased about that.
And as more companies come on board with emergency youth authorization, we'll be able to vaccinate more and more individuals.
So a lot of the timeline is dependent upon volume of vaccine into the state.
But we suspect that vaccinations will go on through the summer, as we haven't even hit the full population yet.
We've only vaccinated about 20% of the population to date.
So it's going to be quite a number of months down the road before we're able to go back to some sense of normalcy, which is, I think, what you're talking about, Representative Edwards, around all the healthcare provider communities doing booster shots, possibly on a yearly basis.
As the volume of vaccination comes into the state, we will be distributing that to the healthcare provider community so they will have a more active role.
They already have an active role, but even a more active role in vaccination.
So we'll be able to move that timeline even closer.
Does that make sure your question?
So from the budget perspective, you'll be doing this for a few months into the next budget cycle?
Yeah, I mean, response will still be going on.
So you know, we'll still have fixed sites probably, you know, through into the summer for sure.
But we're going to be investigating cases and contact tracing for quite a long time to come.
There are still many people who are unvaccinated and COVID is not going away anytime in the near future.
So response will still continue, but we'll be able to sort of shrink the level of response as we, you know, between what we have now and maybe what we have, you know, coming into the fall.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Next slide.
So this is, again, our last slide relative to that is COVID specific.
And this just really demonstrates through our public health lab, the challenges that we've had to this last year.
So this shows, you know, from 2012 through 2020, the volume of testing that our public health lab has done.
And obviously, in 2020, you can see that huge jump.
The yellow is all COVID.
So, you know, we thank our public health lab for the great work that they have done in addition to our case investigation and everybody else who has been in response.
So thank you.
So we'll move on to the next slide.
So in the past few years, we've had a considerable number of successes at the Division of Public Health Services in working with our partners in the community and across the department.
And I would like to just talk about several of them, but this is just a small list of the many outcomes, positive outcomes that we've had within the division.
So as you can see here, almost 76,000 persons with COVID have been investigated.
We have already discussed this, the number of vaccine doses administered.
We also have a vibrant universal childhood vaccine program here with administering 500,000 doses of vaccine to our children across New Hampshire.
We have 1,630 individuals have used our New Hampshire tobacco quit line in 2020.
21% of the callers are very concerned about the impact of tobacco use and COVID as it is a respiratory disease.
Universal blood lead testing, which was newly required for all one and two year olds in New Hampshire over the past year.
The percent of two year olds screened increased from 55% in 2015 to 70% in 2019, thanks to the legislation and we expect that number to continue to increase.
Only 5.6% of families in Healthy Family America, which is a home visiting program, had preterm births last fiscal year.
The national average for the similar program is 11.2%.
And the last state average in 2018 was 8.3%.
We're very proud of that outcome.
Rural health and primary care, those programs supported the claims denial analytics project, credited with saving eight of the 13 critical access hospitals over $29 million over denied claims, which is quite a large savings.
Does that mean that $29 million had been denied and then after this effort, the $29 million was released to the hospitals?
That's correct.
So we'll get a little bit now into the Division of Public Health and exactly what we do and why we do it.
So our mission is really to protect the health of all people.
And under each of these categories, you'll see some of the programs that reflect that particular mission statement.
We target evidence-based strategies that, yes.
I'm sorry, I'm a little slow.
I'm still thinking about the previous slide.
Oh, okay.
We'll go back.
That $29 million, maybe when we're talking about the accounting lines, if somebody could point out to me how much we invested of general funds to recoup that $29 million.
dollars you know obviously if we're paying 50 million to get 29 million that's not very smart but if it's only a1 million, it's brilliant.
So I'd just like to know that later.
Correct.
So just we can actually answer that question now.
Trisha, Deputy Director Trisha Tilly oversees this particular program.
And Tricia, is this program federally funded?
Yes.
So thank you, Representative Edwards, for the question.
This is actually use of our federal funds.
We have a small hospital improvement program.
It's called SHIP, not to be confused with our state health improvement plan, but a small hospital improvement plan.
It's federal dollars.
They come to us and we organize with the feedback from the hospitals, in particular the critical access hospitals, what they need for technical assistance.
And we arrange to bring in the experts to help them.
And this has been an incredibly successful program where they had been seeing this pattern of denied claims.
And so we brought in the folks to say, you know, how can they get those claims fixed on their end?
So I don't have the exact number of this particular program, but it's relatively short changed.
The SHIP program, I could be wrong on this, but certainly is around $150,000 a year of federal dollars.
So no general funds in this particular project.
Sounds brilliant, thank you.
Back to that slide, Trisha.
Next slide.
Trisha is controlling the, as you can see.
Thank you.
So we target evidence-based strategies that we know will improve health.
We ensure equitable access to high-value, effective, preventative-focused healthcare.
We collect and analyze data about health status and community needs and assets and ultimately improve health outcomes.
That's the goal.
Next slide, please.
This is the organizational chart.
It's very hard to see.
I apologize for that.
Of the Division of Public Health Services, so we have seven bureaus.
So I am the director.
We have the deputy director.
You know Deputy Director Tilly.
We have our state epidemiologist, Dr.
Chan.
We have an administrative assistant, and then we have the seven bureaus listed below.
And we're going to go through each bureau to give you additional information.
Yes, Representative Ezra.
So which of these bureaus, if any of them, are the ones where we have an arrangement with UNH to subsidize about half of their salary so that they also work with us?
Thank you.
So this provides more detail relative to the bureaus that I just mentioned previously.
So the Bureau of Population Health and Community Services promotes health across the age continuum and reduces health inequities.
And some of the programs here are chronic disease programs and screenings, maternal and child health, prenatal child health, newborn screening, injury prevention, teen pregnancy, nutrition, tobacco prevention, and cessation.
Then we have the Bureau of Infectious Disease Control, which many of you have become very familiar with during the COVID pandemic.
This Bureau identifies, investigates, monitors, and prevents infectious disease.
So they do disease surveillance and investigation, vaccine distribution, public health emergency preparedness and response, provider training and education, financial assistance to people infected with HIV and tuberculosis, and vaccines for children.
We have the Bureau of Public Health Laboratories, which provides clinical and environmental laboratory testing.
So the public health lab provides environmental health and biomonitoring testing, as well as drinking water testing, food emergency response, microbiology and virology, and sentinel laboratory training, education and quality improvement.
And this is around referencing external lab training on biological agents and continuity of operations in biosafety.
So we'll go to the next slide.
The next bureau is the Bureau of Public Health Statistics and Informatics.
This particular Bureau collects, analyzes, and distributes New Hampshire health statistics and oversight and maintenance of systems that move data.
Some of the areas that they work on is the health data portal, which is called Wisdom, data statistics and management, and informatics and electronic reporting.
The Bureau of Health Protection, which assures public safety from environmental public health risks, provides environmental health and biomonitoring.
Oh, I think that this is an error, and this is through the public health lab, but they do do environmental health work.
They do, oh, there was an error here.
So this, I apologize for the error here.
This is around the public health lab.
They do the lead prevention work, so healthy homes work.
They do food, the food protection and radiological health work.
The Bureau of Public Health Systems Policy and Performance, which is public health systems quality improvement and performance management, is working in the state health assessment and the state health improvement plan, which Representative Edwards is quite familiar with, Operational planning quality improvement, oversees the 13 public health regional networks and provides healthcare workforce recruitment, retention and development and therapeutic cannabis.
Next slide, please.
Then we have the Bureau of Public Health Preparedness, Response and Recovery, and this is a new bureau that we'll be talking about a little bit later.
This is preparing for and acting quickly in emergencies and disasters.
We manage the continuity of operations planning, actually, for the department, safety and response plans for all hazard events.
The bureau maintains the all-hazard warehouse, including the commissioner's stockpile of personal protective equipment.
It maintains the New Hampshire Hospital's information management system, which does patient tracking, incident reporting, and inventory management, and this is used in emergency response, and supports behavioral health recovery after disasters.
And then, um, Lisa, can I jump in just for a second?
Of course.
I just want to mention that Bureau that Lisa just discussed, that Bureau did exist in the department.
It is new to public health.
It was previously reported directly to the commissioner, um, and we have now moved it to report to the director of public health.
Thank you, Karen.
So when we look at it, it'll have FY20 and 21 money?
It should.
I don't remember if it does when we move an accounting unit, so we might have to refer you to another area to see the 20 and 21, but it did exist previously.
Lastly, the prescription drug monitoring program, which is currently in a different agency within the state, but within the governor's budget has moved over to public health.
And this drug monitoring program enhances patient care and prevents misuse and diversion of controlled substances.
And this program manages the web-based database of the prescribing, opioid prescribing history and other controlled substance history.
It provides feedback and training for prescribers and pharmacists, and it analyzes data trends to inform policymakers and stakeholders about prescription patterns of controlled substances.
So I need to be clear again, because the title, New This Biennium, which one is this biennium?
The one we're in, or are you referring to the one that we're budgeting?
So the Bureau of Public Health Preparedness, Response, and Recovery has moved over to public health.
So that is, it is current this year.
It's a recent move.
So it hasn't been that long since it's been part of the Division of Public Health from the Commissioner's office.
The prescription drug monitoring program is a program.
So when it is said new to DPHS, this program is within the 22-23 budget, but currently is not within the Division of Public Health Services.
Okay.
Thank you.
Next slide.
So I thought it would be important to talk about, you know, how we deliver services within the world of public health.
And you can see here that there are many sectors involved in implementing services and programs for the citizens of New Hampshire, because we know that ensuring health outcomes happens at the community level with state support, which is how we proceed and how we manage our work that we do.
So we work with hospitals, community health centers, the two health departments across the state, the public health networks, and all the stakeholders within communities, including businesses, the faith communities, family resource centers, first responders, and so forth and so on, as is on the list.
In New Hampshire, different from other states, we don't have fully functional health departments based in communities other than Manchester and Nashua.
So we rely on our community-based public health network system to be able to implement public health services at the community level.
These 13 public health entities are connected to fiscal agents, mostly nonprofits.
Some of them are standalone and many of them are connected to other nonprofit communities.
So at this point, I'm going to turn the presentation over to Deputy Director Tilley to continue on in the presentation.
I will move this slide as soon as it allows me to move this slide.
There we go.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Representative Edwards and committee.
So from here, we would like to talk a little bit about some of the major accomplishments over the past biennium.
So in July 2019, right at the beginning of our current biennium, we published our DPHS operational plan.
And the goal of this really was to refresh and affirm our vision.
I've already put those two together, as I always say, the mission, the mission, vision, and values to really develop a roadmap for our operational work to really strengthen our foundation and focused on planning, communication, workforce, data and information, and service delivery.
So that's not to be confused with the work that we are beginning to undertake right now, which is our state health assessment and our state health improvement plan.
That operational plan was really our readiness document to make sure that we had our own house in order, that we could move forward in addressing the larger issues that are impacting the state.
So as many of you know, our SHA and our SHIP, the state health assessment, the state health improvement plan, are underway right now with a council, a legislatively appointed council, and we are deep in the weeds right now in the data collection process and the assessment process.
Core also to our value of collaboration, we are an active participant on a number of integration activities, both within the department as well as within our communities, and those really focus on everything from environmental health to the prevention of adverse childhood experiences to the opioid crisis.
We are participants in legislative councils and study committees.
We have shared federally funded projects across divisions and departments, and we've used our expertise in data analysis to provide the data needed in many of these projects to improve health outcomes in each of these areas.
So, as we think about some of those key accomplishments, we're going to go down a little bit again, sort of bureau by bureau, to give you a very high-level overview.
Of course, we have to start with COVID, and as we've already discussed, most of the time when public health is working well, we are invisible.
No one really thinks about whether their food and water is safe.
We usually don't think about whether we can access primary care.
Vaccines usually just appear at our doctor's office or our provider's office.
And data is hopefully usually available when we need it.
But the pandemic threw that all under the bus, and suddenly our public health systems were frankly stressed, and we experienced strains on our healthcare system and, of course, an economic fallout.
Luckily, infectious disease investigation and emergency preparedness are the bread and butter of what we do.
As we've already heard, in the past year, we've investigated, again, almost 80,000 cases, vaccinated, fully vaccinated, almost 10% of our population.
Meanwhile, we continue to have some of the best rates in the country in things like childhood vaccine.
The day-to-day work continues while we are aggressively managing and mitigating this pandemic.
So our laboratory, as you noted in that earlier slide, has been working seven days a week, two shifts, and testing more than 220,000 samples for COVID compared to our normal volume in a year of about 40,000 samples, all while continuing that other important work in environmental health, in food and water testing.
Our emergency services unit, as you just heard, has moved over to DPHS from the commissioner's office, and that was really done for better alignment.
They have been working hand in hand with our infectious disease folks, our incident management team, homeland security, and the entire COVID response.
And we found that this move has been really helpful to ensure communication and alignment of efforts.
I have a question there on the lab.
Yes, sorry.
Is this lab fully functionally and physically separated from the lab that's used in the criminal justice system of New Hampshire?
Correct, yes.
We work together on some projects, but it is a separate lab.
The public health lab is here at 29 Hazen Drive.
Where is the criminal justice lab?
I don't know that answer right off the top of my head.
But it's not in the same building even?
No.
All right.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Great.
So let's focus a little bit here on some of the other core areas of public health.
First off, certainly population health.
New Hampshire continues to show significant progress with many chronic diseases, maternal and child health outcomes, and other population health measures such as teen births.
We're the best in the country for the lowest number of teen births.
Adult tobacco use continues to trend downward as compared to our youth vaping, which is really concerning going upwards.
But adults, once you get older, you start to realize that you need to cut back on that.
New Hampshire continues to rank among the top states for health status for both adults and children.
We've launched a new campaign to address this youth vaping crisis called Save Your Breath New Hampshire.
And it is a social media campaign that's had over a million impressions of likes and shares and all the things that you do on social media.
It's on Snapchat and YouTube and TikTok and not just the places like Facebook where old people are.
It's really aimed at that youth population because we've seen that this is really becoming quite an epidemic, which we are very concerned is going to have really long-term health outcomes and cost outcomes for the state of New Hampshire.
Among our public health protection programs, we continue to work hand-in-hand with the Department of Environmental Services, which actually is also here in 29 Hazen Drive.
That really eases some of our collaboration, and we use this to continue to track and reduce environmental health exposures.
And because we know that children actually often face hazards where they live or where they play or where they go to school or learn, some of our work right now is really focused on helping folks like child care providers be able to site their programs in places that are healthy.
And we use our expertise in data and health promotion and communication to really work collaboratively both with our Department of Environmental Services and folks like in our in our Child Care Bureau in other areas of the department.
Our informatics.
So I have a couple of questions.
They're kind of different.
But so in terms of performance metrics, you mentioned suicide prevention earlier, and here we have tobacco secession efforts.
And I'm just curious if we what kind of metric we use to evaluate whether or not a program is effective?
Because it just seems difficult to measure whether a program has prevented a suicide or prevented somebody from smoking.
And so I'm just curious what kind of benchmarks and metrics you can use when you can't measure a negative.
Sure.
You know, this is the problem with prevention overall, and you'll sort of hear this repeated in any of our preventative work, whether it's suicide, tobacco, you know, working in prevention programs with young children, it's really hard.
And I think you've landed on that.
So what we do is we use the evidence.
So we know that there are science-based programs that have gone through rigorous peer-reviewed journal studies.
And so we model our programs with fidelity to those programs that have been shown in those rigorous evaluations to have been effective.
So that's one way that we can feel confident that what we're doing is working.
And then we measure ourselves against that sort of fidelity to those programs.
We certainly measure the process.
So someday when we're just talking, I'd like to dive into what's in those academic papers, because it just sounded like you said that in these heavily rigorous peer-reviewed journals, they're still measuring against something.
There's still evidence.
Yeah.
And usually they have- That's what I'm really getting at, is what is the thing they measure against.
Sure.
In many of those, there's comparison groups in a way that we would not, when we put out a program, we tend not to do it only for one segment of the population and then measure outcomes of a group that didn't receive that intervention.
And some of them are long-term.
So things like early childhood, they've, you know, looked at that, the life course of that child for if that early, you know, what that early childhood intervention was, and then what their third grade reading score was, and then whether they were involved in juvenile justice, or whether, you know, they went on to have a successful life.
So those are the studies that we base on those rigorous evidence-based programs.
That's just an example.
Okay, that's great.
I'm not trying to be rude, even though I am, but we just got to get to the 70 accounts.
So I got another short question for you.
Great.
On protection, you've got visual inspections for food establishments.
Yeah.
And that excites the telemedicine guy in me.
So I would like to hear what you're doing and how great it is.
Well, I will give a good, I will give you an overview, a very high level overview.
So, you know, COVID happened and yet our restaurants were still open.
And quite honestly, they had lots of questions as they were implementing the governor's executive orders.
And we wanted to make sure that our staff were safe as well as sending them out.
So we have started doing these virtual inspections using both video technology and our food inspectors to help understand what their challenges were, what their questions were.
We have Michelle Roberge sitting in the audience if you want to get deeper in that, or we can come back to you later on and provide some additional information exactly of how many and where they were and what the feedback has been.
Other than generally that feedback's been incredibly positive to be able to make sure that our food inspectors are available to our folks around the state.
Okay, so I don't need to know more before the 24th of March, but it is a topic of interest.
We'd love to get more information to you on that.
It could be very powerful and something that should be sustained after the pandemic, I hope.
So, all right.
Sure.
Thanks.
No, absolutely.
So we'll just round up today.
This slide, again, informatics, data governance, integration.
This has been a tremendous work that we've done, again, within our department.
We're strong partners with Dave Wieters to ensure that as a department, we have one governance system, and we are looking at security in a very robust way.
And then, of course, what's available to the public, what you all see are these fancy new dashboards that are interactive and available in a transparent and timely way.
Never before have we given you day-to-day data.
And so we've really been excited by the progress that they've made.
In a policy and performance world, which is my world, you know, again, we continue to support our health workers with something called the state loan repayment program.
And that's where we help do loan repayment for providers that serve underserved communities.
And then of course, we've been providing pandemic support for our critical access hospitals.
As Lisa noted, we support the entire system, we support the entire state, but then we really focused in on some of those that are most vulnerable.
And in the healthcare system, that's our critical access I'm going to go ahead and get started.
Lisa noted we support the entire system, we support the entire state, but then we really focus in on some of those that are most vulnerable, and in the healthcare system, that's our critical access hospitals in our rural areas.
So I'll flip it over here to some of the challenges.
I can talk about the great things forever, but you certainly want to know where some of the areas that we're a little stuck and have had some uphill challenges.
So structurally, we are continually faced with maintaining, replacing our critical laboratory equipment, recruiting a pipeline of qualified staff, especially to support our core mission as our aging population, our aging staff, you know, go out to the great beyond of retirement as we wish them well, we need to ensure that we've got a pipeline of folks that are willing to come and work with us to maintain these core services.
We have other challenges.
So on the aging laboratory instrumentation, I assume almost all of that is capital.
Okay, so that's in the capital budget that we won't be talking about today.
Some of it is capital.
Some of it we put into other federal funding where it's appropriate and within our budgets.
Okay.
Other challenges that are more population-based, you know, so things like an older housing stock.
So you might think that's not, that doesn't have anything to do with public health.
Well, in fact, that older housing stock means that we have housing with significant lead risk and lead risk to children.
So, you know, we have disparities where we even see things like our new Americans, new refugees, people of color are moving into older housing stock and have these higher rates of lead exposure as a result of environmental exposures in the house.
We were thrilled that in several sessions ago, we made it mandatory now that all one and two-year-olds, regardless, are tested for lead because even though we have disparities in some populations we may think about, like if I were to ask you to write down where you think that problem is, we also have disparities that individuals across the economic spectrum are moving into homes that are older, doing some home repairs, and end up poisoning their own children with lead.
So it's important across the population, although we're very focused on probably the most vulnerable populations, making sure those in rental markets get access to screening and then the care that they need.
I don't know if you can see me when I raise my hand.
I'm looking at my notes on the slide.
So it's a little.
Okay.
Thank you.
I just hate barging in.
Okay.
But so on refugees, do we do a screening of adult refugees when they first get to New Hampshire so that we have a lead baseline?
So we do screening.
There's our Office of Minority Health, our health equity, now that it's called, works closely with the community and they do a number of health screenings there.
But we know in particular this issue around blood lead levels, we test the children within three months of arrival when they land in the housing here.
So, you know, we also know that, again, that older housing stock, if you've lived here for generations or you're a new American, older housing stock is a risk.
I don't doubt any of that.
I'm just wondering if we get a baseline when the newly arrived get here so that we don't assume it's our own lead environment as opposed to the environment they're escaping from, which is probably not great either.
Nope.
So, again, there are some health screenings that are done and coordinated through the Office of Health Equity.
Environmental, some of the other challenges we have, again, population-based, we have a really high rate of bladder cancer.
And in fact, we have the highest rate of bladder cancer in the country.
That's not a cancer we talk about.
There's not like a big bladder cancer month.
But it can be tied back to some environmental issues to arsenic that is in our private water wells.
And so we have, you know, this is a place where we look at it both from a population health perspective, and also try to ensure that we put in functions like really support well water testing, and really try to provide education to folks of why that's so important, because there are health risks that could come from your private well.
And, you know, while we've seen improvements in unintentional injury deaths, including overdose over the past year or so, you know, we know that New Hampshire residents are still disproportionately impacted by substance and alcohol use, you know, all of which create costly and poor health outcomes at the end of the day from infections, from cancer, and then things even like neonatal abstinence syndrome among the little ones.
So these are some of the high-level challenges that we're facing within these bureaus, across these bureaus, and it impacts our entire work.
So I'm going to stop there.
Actually, I will move on.
I think Karen wanted me to jump to the end of our presentation right now and talk a little bit about some priority needs.
So you're going to see me flip through these slides very quickly to get to the end because it's my last slide.
So don't have an epileptic seizure watching those slides move.
Whoops, we'll go back to this and then it's the end here.
I think it's the very last slide.
There you go.
Yeah, thank you so much.
So, you know, one of the things that we have been talking about a little bit are some of the needs.
And DPHS has a couple of requests that are not in our budget right now, but we did note as priorities.
So, and this is one where also the governor's office is particularly interested in understanding how we might be able to better support prevention services for young families and young children and their families.
So many different services are available to guide and assist parents-to-be and parents of young children in those early stages of raising a family.
In public health, we focus on the programs that have been shown to improve health outcomes, as I was talking about before, such as maternal depression, premature birth, low birth weight, neonatal abstinence syndrome, and other adverse childhood experiences that ultimately lead to costly and poor chronic disease and behavioral health problems as those children grow up into adults.
So some of these programs include our Healthy Families America, which you've heard about, which is our home visiting program.
We support activities at our family resource centers that I know that you've heard about when Chris Santanello did her presentation.
We have programs like our community collaborations, which again is some federal funding that we get to support communities in coordinating around working with young kids.
All of these services are slightly different, but they share the same goal of promoting healthy pregnancies, positive birth outcomes, and creating those safe and nurturing environments for kids and families to grow.
So public health has a number of federally funded programs that do this.
But we in the current biennium, so not the next biennium where you're looking at the budget, but currently we had had the opportunity to use some general funds to be able to do some additional outreach to populations we weren't able to cover with those federally funded programs.
So in particular, we did some really interesting work around substance exposed infants, ensuring that, and we work very closely with our prenatal providers, our hospitals, to ensure that they were doing their safe plans of care, which is something that DCYF requires them to do to get families set up for success.
And then we were helping them understand how to connect to programs like Our Home Visiting, which has that evidence base to ensure that we can get closer to lower preterm birth rates, lower low birth weights, getting families screened for depression, and connecting them all while doing developmental services for their kids as well.
So that's been a really exciting project where we've doubled the number of substance exposed infants that were in some of those programs, those pilots that we funded with general funds.
So we just wanted to leave this as a note, sort of as a consideration as you're thinking about the budget, that there may be opportunities to continue this really important work.
So I will leave it there and hand it over to Karen, unless there's any more questions.
I'll stop sharing.
Sorry, I put myself on mute.
So Representative Wollner has a question.
Thank you.
I never know whether you can see the hand up.
I could see you.
I was just speaking to a muted mic, so it wasn't very effective.
Thank you.
Trish, I was wondering about when we get to the pages in the budget book, where those priority programs are that are not funded, but you did request them of the governor's budget, but they were not in the governor's budget.
Will you be sure to point those out to us as we go along?
Yes, yes, we will do that with Karen and Shelly's help.
Okay, great.
Thank you.
Ms.
Tilling, I'm looking at the bottom rung here where it says home visiting and outreach to families.
And I'm just curious about the nature of those home visits.
Is there a percentage that's truly voluntary where the parents want you in?
And is there another portion that's court compelled somehow, whether a search warrant or a court order, this is 100% voluntary?
Everything we do in public health is 100% voluntary.
It's prevention-based.
These are not what we're trying to do.
I think you sometimes hear Director Ripson talk about keeping people out of the front door of DCYF.
We're trying to keep people somewhere out in the yard, like somewhere way before they get to the porch or the front door, that we're really providing those prevention services, which really means family support, parenting education, education around childhood development, to really make sure that those families stay as safe as possible before there's a problem, which is why it's really important for us to begin prenatally.
And we're right there from the beginning when those babies are born.
And it's a partnership.
So it's not coerced.
It's not scary.
Like, you know, DCYF can feel scary sometimes.
This is really prevention.
So we work hand in hand with child welfare to keep folks out.
So that sounds good.
Do you see any pressures building within this community to want to be able to compel home visits?
So I think, you know, certainly Director Ribson can speak better to that.
You know, there are individuals who would like to be able to offer this service to more folks.
You know, we've been, because we have limited federal dollars, we've narrowed down to, you know, people that might come with some risk factors, so risk factors like a history of substance use or, you know, poverty in particular and, you know, other, you know, other factor, young age is another one.
So, you know, really young moms and dads.
So there are some people that would like to open that door a little bit wider.
but certainly not in the public health world.
Is there any movement for compelling anyone to participate in something they don't want to participate in?
Thank you for that.
Representative Walner, your hand is up.
Representative Walner, can you hear me?
She can't hear you, Jess.
I'm going to assume her hand is up from the previous question and move on.
Okay.
Thank you.
It's entertaining as I expected.
I appreciate it.
We try.
Thank you.
Karen will be great.
All right.
Go ahead and share my screen.
So because all of these accounting units are straight through, I'm not gonna bounce between the presentation and the accounting units.
We're just gonna start on page 1014 and go all the way through to, I think it's like 1098 or something like that.
So the first accounting unit on page 1014 is accounting unit 5110, which is the office of the director.
Give me just a second.
I'm trying to get my screens ready to do this with you.
Contact shifting.
So this is 5110.
Thank you.
context shifting.
So this is 5110.
So this is an area so Shelley has been in her role about three years about the same amount of time as I have been and that's something I should have shared when we talked about finance at a grand level.
Other than Athena, who you saw present with Medicaid, everyone else at a senior level in finance has been in their role less than three years.
Some have been with the department a very long time, but they've only been in their roles for years.
So we are a very new finance group.
And so that's why you're seeing a lot of changes and a lot of improvements, because we are working hard to change the way we do business.
And so one of the things that public health finance worked really hard on was cost allocation.
And they're continuing to do that, which is awesome.
And so that's why you see a shift here in the revenue.
And you see agency income here because we are actually cost allocating from agency income that's received throughout the division to the director level.
So that's a really exciting thing for us to start making those shifts.
So as I'm looking at the personnel I see two permanent and two unclassified.
Yes.
And I think there are three of those four people probably on the call right now.
Did the fourth person get in trouble and not get invited?
No.
So actually, Shelly would have been in the finance accounting unit.
So this is Lisa and Trish, and then I assume that's your admin assistant and I'm not sure who the fourth one is.
If you have a second admin, I'm not sure.
Can I jump in?
Yes.
So the two unclassified positions, are they listed here?
Yeah, in this particular accounting unit are Lisa Morris and Ben Chan.
Oh, it's Ben.
OK.
The two permanent classifieds are administrative positions.
So I thought I had assumed that Ms.
Tilley being a deputy director would be one of those four people.
You will find Ms.
Tilley in accounting unit 5362.
Representative Irv, do you have any questions on any of these line items?
I know you've been combing through these.
No, this one actually, if you look at it, looks pretty favorable to us in terms of federal funding.
Thank you.
So that was just one and we have 69 more?
Something like that, yes.
Oh okay, keep going.
We're gonna get there.
We might even get to have lunch today.
Unemployment compensation 8579 self-explanatory.
So 5262 is informatics and health statistics.
So my order is different than your order because I'm using the spreadsheet because I can keep notes right on it.
And that doesn't work very well.
Okay.
So, oh, there it is.
Yep.
I got it.
So you have eight permanent classified and you're, you're adding one here.
Can you talk about how many you actually have hired at the moment and what this new role will do?
Shelley, is that position moved from somewhere else?
Yeah, we didn't add any new positions.
We just realigned positions.
So we took a position out of a different accounting unit that really belongs in with informatics and data analytics and moved it in here.
I am not sure of the vacancy rate off the top of my head.
So I would have to get back to you on that.
So I'm looking, just so you know, if you didn't hear earlier, I'm looking at the aggregate level for public health.
You know, how many folks you have hired today versus authorized.
So all right.
Thank you.
Do you have any questions, Representative Earth?
No.
I think the next one is 8667 Behavioral Risk Factor Surveillance Survey.
What are our private, excuse me, we have private local funds going to this.
What is that?
Those funds come to us either from Dartmouth or from UNH.
They also come to us from organizations like the Alzheimer's Association.
It just feels unusual for people to give the state money.
What is incentivizing them to give us this money?
If I may interrupt, if that's okay.
The organizations provide those funds so that we can add questions to the CDC survey called the Behavioral Risk Factor Surveillance System because they want to know about health outcomes in their particular areas of interest.
We're helping them do research and they're helping us with their research money.
You could look at it that way.
Thank you for not correcting me in public.
All right.
Okay.
Coming down to the bottom of page 1019 is 2218, the hospital flex program.
This is 100% federally funded.
What are we asking the hospitals to flex?
I'll take this one as well.
Thank you.
This is funds through our rural health and primary care program, and this provides support to hospital programs to do different TA and support to maintain their health care system.
So we work closely with the hospital association and the foundation for healthy families.
The next one is 2,219, which is the small hospital improvement, which the director spoke to earlier.
There is a small amount of general funds in this accounting amount.
So to your question earlier, Chair, it is, we're only spending about $160,000 there.
What can you do with $160,000?
It just seems like kind of an odd number.
It's not big enough to really have a program.
It's not small enough to just eliminate.
When we spend this money, when we spend the federal money, what work or infrastructure is actually getting built?
So many times we're hiring consultants to work with the small hospitals.
So like that claims denial program, we've hired consultants to come in and provide training and the small hospitals participate.
They help us choose what it is that they want to focus on and how to best spend those funds to really improve their clinical care and their bottom line.
Okay.
Very good.
Quick question.
Yes.
Representative Irv.
So I really did very small numbers, but just like curiosity, is there a general funds match required?
Why is $3,000 in there?
I'd like to respond to that.
This was overlooked actually.
in the governor's phase, we made a lot of corrections because we had mistakenly budgeted general funds in many of our accounting units because of class 41 and 42 and it was a new tool that we used that we we weren't used to so we made a lot of corrections but I think I missed this particular accounting unit because this one is supposed to be 100 federal so we'll be putting in a budget change request to get that corrected.
Thank you, that makes more sense.
Sure.
5362 at the bottom of the page here is public health systems policy and performance.
I'm not hearing any questions, so.
No, I do have a question.
So this looks relatively level funded from your adjusted authorized, but it's a jump from 20 actual in general funds.
So why is it bouncing around?
I guess what I'm wondering.
Shelley, was there an issue there of the general fund earned from fiscal year 20?
It's possible Karen.
We also, this account.
the general fund earned from fiscal year 20?
It's possible Karen.
We also, this accounting unit now has the deputy director in it and it didn't before and it doesn't currently.
So her position is allocated so there would be more general funds coming in here as well.
And I can check on the actual amounts to see what that entails.
Thanks.
Sure.
Okay 79.60.
So I guess you said you're going to get back to us, but the FY20 at $45,000 jump into a quarter million in the next year and then staying at that level, that's just a really big jump.
So you're going to explain that?
Yes.
okay the next accounting unit is 7965 which is rural health Okay.
The next accounting unit is 7965, which is rural health and primary care.
What was that number again, Karen?
7965.
This one kind of did a yo-yo.
From 20 to 21, it went down a lot and then it climbed back up in 22.
Is this the accounting unit where SLRP is?
Yes.
So the increase, part of the increase that you're seeing there is there were funds for SLRP, for the state loan repayment fund, that were appropriated in for fiscal year 20 and 21.
And so some of those contracts did not go through GNC until the end of fiscal year 20.
So what is shown in 22 and 23 is funding those contracts.
So the SLRP checks to the students or the professionals is in line 102 expense?
I think it might be in 103.
Are you okay, it is 102.
No, I'm sorry, you're right.
It is in 103.
Contracts for operational services is what I assume OP means.
Yes.
How many SLRT beneficiaries do you think there were, not looking for an exact number, but how many are projected for FY21 SLRP beneficiaries?
I'll take that.
We have usually between 70 and 90 in a fiscal year.
It varies because depending on your profession, we reimburse at different rates.
So a medical doctor gets a higher loan repayment than, say, an M layback.
Okay, so 70 to 90 currently, and then we're tripling the money in the next budget.
So what's your projected client count?
So although the class 103 only chose $250,000, there was actually an HB4 appropriation of $4,000,000.
It was several million dollars.
So that would not be reflected in the adjusted authorized there.
But we're projecting to not spend about $4,000,000 of that currently.
I understand it's just the opposite of that, that the HB4 is in the adjusted authorized.
It is not.
It's not there until we appropriate it.
So once it's appropriated, then it will show.
It does show in our current...
Actually, we appropriated it in fiscal year 20, so that's why it's not showing in 21, and it's non-lapsing.
You have a follow-up, and then Representative Wollner is ready.
Well, you say it's non-lapsing.
How did the adjusted authorized go down from FY20?
When it's non-lapsing, it doesn't change the adjusted authorized in the future years.
So how do we see that?
In our statement of appropriations, it shows as a balance forward.
Okay.
So back to your statement about until you authorize it, it doesn't show up.
So does that mean some HP4 things are already in the adjusted authorized or none are in there yet?
So most of them we appropriated in fiscal year 20.
If they were non-lapsing in the biennium, there were some HP4 appropriations, I think, that were designated for each year.
So those we would have appropriated already, I believe.
So they should be showing in the adjusted authorized for 21.
But if they were appropriated in 20 and not spent, you wouldn't see them here.
Okay.
So you acknowledge that the adjusted authorized is higher than the budget, 21 versus 21.
So because of the carry forward we do have enough funds we're not needing to transfer funds from anywhere else or anything like that.
no i didn't mean specifically in this um account i mean generally overall the the your fy 21 adjusted authorized total general funds is higher than your fy 21 budgeted general funds so So does that mean that some of those accounts have had their HB4 numbers?
What was the word used?
Authorized?
So they appear- Appropriated?
Appropriated.
I would say yes, but I'd have to walk through each of the different HB4 appropriations.
Well, what else would be in the adjusted authorized other than HB4 appropriations?
HB3 appropriations.
It's HB3 and HB4, right?
So it's all the HB3 appropriations.
I'm talking about the difference between HB3 and adjusted authorized.
So what changes with adjusted authorized are things that we've either gone to fiscal committee or were in other budget bills.
So it may not have always been in HB 4.
There were appropriations in HB 11 last biennium as well.
There might have been another one too.
So it could include anything that was in a different bill.
Okay.
Thanks.
So Representative Walmer, you're on mute.
Thank you.
My phone was ringing, so I muted.
So you said that there were $6 million in House Bill 4.
and we did not spend down that $6 million.
What was that $6 million scheduled to do?
What were we supposed to be doing with that $6 million?
So it was intended to be used for the state loan repayment program.
The funds were not spent, of course, during the pandemic because there was a spending freeze during, well, the pandemic is still happening, but during the beginning of the pandemic, there was a spending freeze.
And we actually temporarily used those general funds to do things like buy PPE and all that kind of stuff until there were federal funds available and then we transferred those funds back.
It is my understanding and I would really direct the question to the governor's office that because I don't know the new program that well but there's a program in HB2 that's intended to replace this program.
So we've only funded those contracts at current levels, understanding that the intent is for there to be a different program.
Could I follow up?
Do you know where in HB 2 that is?
It must be assigned to a different division.
I believe it is.
I think it's education if I remember correctly, but I don't know that for certain.
I would definitely direct that to the governor's office.
Okay, chairman, I think that might be something we would want to talk to division two a little bit about that particular program, especially since before it was in the public health budget.
Okay.
You can.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'll just agree.
I'm not sure when the division chairs do their huddles with their committees, other than full finance committee hearings.
so so so i would encourage you to go ahead and make an informal phone call to start the conversation and we'll figure out how to have it formally.
OK, thank you.
I guess my last question around SLRP is, your hand's still up, Representative Warner.
My last last question around slurp is do we have any measures of effectiveness because i would hope that what we're doing with this money is trying to incentivize people to move here or people to stay here and because we don't have enough money to pay our all our health care professionals um to to for the status quo so So how do we know that these are effective spends?
I'll take that.
So as part of their contract, they have to commit to staying serving an underserved healthcare provider for three years.
That's the, you know, as part of the terms of the contract, and we are collecting data now trying to figure out sort of the long term, how long people stay.
We're particularly happy if they stay where there are, but we're also happy if after those three years or even within those three years, if they move around from, you know, for example, one federally qualified health center to another federally qualified health center, we consider that a still a net win for the state of New Hampshire that we've attracted and kept that kind of personnel.
Thank you for the answer.
Representative Weiler, you have a question, sir?
Let's see if the space bar works.
It works fine.
All right.
I just wanted to tell Representative Walner that the area I've been working on with the 529 program on page 68 in the HB2 is where the governor has switched some of these programs where they're paying people that studied medicine.
and it's under this, the money that comes from Fidelity, from the 529.
And it used to all go to scholarships and endowments, but now the governor has changed that around and he's taken 60% of it to go to these scholarships.
But what that means is we don't need general funds for this $6 million that might have been in there before, because now he's getting it out of the Fidelity money, which has increased quite a bit.
Thank you.
Great.
Chairman Weiler, what was that page again?
It was 68?
Page 68.
It starts with the endowment scholarship fund, and then it sticks in another part.
it goes for five pages, describe the whole thing.
So what I've done is after meeting with the 529, I put in an amendment on that page where it goes 20% to direct student and 20% to endowment.
The 529 committee themselves or the commission wanted to have 70% direct scholarships and 30%.
So I rewrote that A and B and C.
So you might see that in amendments later on.
But that's where money is now going from for scholarships to people that did the, you know, the stuff at the mill yard with artificial limbs and doctors and nurses and so on, which is a good source of the money and it doesn't have to come out of general funds.
So this $6 million should be saved.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate that.
Can we do the next one?
Sure.
The next one is Amy, 11 Preventative Health Block Grant.
You're dropping a couple of permanent classifier.
Are those being transferred somewhere?
Shall we?
Yes, they're moving into other AUs.
One of the AUs that we looked at earlier, the 5262, is taking one of those positions.
Contracts for program services is the primary expense, as well as grants for public assistance and relief.
Could you just give us a good thumbnail on both of those expense items, 74 and 102?
I don't know the contracts generally do in this area.
Maybe Trish can.
Sure.
So thank you.
This is something called the Preventative Health Block Grant.
It is a large Thank you.
It is a large block grant, obviously, so it's flexible funding for core public health services.
So we use these funds for our public health networks, and we also use them to plug holes to be able to provide services where we have no other funding to do that.
So we can broadly address public health needs with these dollars.
But primarily, we're spending a good bit of the money with public health networks to carry out local public health activity.
And because it's a block grant, we don't necessarily have any success metrics with it.
We just realize it's critical infrastructure and therefore it's wise money.
Each of our contracts all have performance measures attached to them.
All right.
Well, good.
Do you have a question here, Representative Wirth?
Thank you.
All right.
The next.
Representative Irv?
I'm not, thank you.
Alright, the next one is 3899, which is the therapeutic cannabis program.
So the therapeutic cannabis program.
I'm personally worried about the long-term stability of our alternative treatment centers as every region around us goes to legal recreational marijuana.
I don't know how these folks are going to compete with the black market in the future.
This outside of this budget conversation probably.
But do we have any thoughts on the long-term viability of the alternative treatment centers and whether or not we need to continue the therapeutic cannabis program forever?
That's me again.
So thank you for that question around therapeutic program.
So I'll answer your second question first, which is the reason to continue.
And we certainly believe that there is reason to continue so that people who access this for their therapeutic needs have access to safe and legal cannabis that they use to address any number of healthcare considerations.
We certainly don't want to encourage anyone to be using a black market.
A, it's illegal, and B, you don't know what you're getting.
This is a much safer program for them.
In terms of the economic viability of it, there are some policy measures that have gotten through the House and the Senate, and some have made progress and some haven't.
Things about whether or not the ATCs need to be for-profit or nonprofit and move to an LLC status.
That's one thing.
We've also increased, we have ensured that they have access around the state so that they've created some satellite shop, which we think also increases some access and help them with their economic viability.
Are you familiar with any requests to be able to have mobile dispensaries so that they can serve the rural clientele better?
Sure.
Thank you.
So there's no legislation right now making that available.
We would have to dig a little bit deeper into both the law and the administrative rules of this program.
It's highly complex, but that is something that certainly could be considered in the future.
I can tell you during the pandemic, we made administrative rule changes and waivers during the pandemic to allow things like curbside pickup so that, again, many of these folks are highly compromised.
They may have cancer.
They may have other conditions.
So we were able to address their needs, keeping them safe and keeping the ATC staff safe.
That sounds like you think that maybe we did during the pandemic do mobile services to the doorstep.
We did not.
so there was no cannabis van that went driving around from place to place.
Individuals came to the ATCs and we allowed a rule waiver to allow the ATC staff to leave the premises with the product and deliver to the car curbside.
That's a security, was a calculated security risk.
We've had no problems.
It's highly secure, highly camera-ed.
Every step of that product is watched.
And it was very successful and will likely keep it.
In fact, some of our sites right now have built in.
One had, originally, it was in an old bank, so they used the drive-through window, which was very successful.
And we have a new site that's employing a new drive-through window because again it keeps the the patients safe and it keeps the staff safe.
Okay thank you.
Are there any other questions here?
Representative Weiler?
Thank you.
I'm just looking at I know we talked about the 27th pay period.
Is that reflected in class 10 or is that the additional fringe benefits in class 42?
That would be in class 10 would be the extra pay period.
So it's going up like $6 million.
That's the 27th pay period.
It doesn't include pay increases and so on.
Are you looking at the totals for the entire Bureau?
I'm looking at the page before, the class 10.
That one there.
So it goes from 120 to 129.
Yeah, that's a pretty good bump.
So that's not this.
So one would think if 22 was the 27th pay period, that class 10 would go down in 23, perhaps.
Oh, I'm sorry, the extra pay period is in fiscal year 23.
i'm sorry thank you you're welcome representative waller actually i wanted to know which year the extra pay period was thank you great minds okay um all right so my big concern about the ATCs is that they got to remain price competitive in order to be viable over the long run.
And so, but so anyways, let's go on beyond that.
All right, so that completes that bureau.
So we're moving on to the Bureau for Public Health Protection.
And the first accounting unit in that is 5390, which is food protection.
Okay, this is a good one.
This is one of my favorite ones.
I like protected food.
So the FDA for the federal government has the primary mission of doing food protection.
So we have a local responsibility.
What are we doing with these 14 people in New Hampshire?
So, Representative Edwards, this is Lisa Morris.
So they are food inspectors.
They also work on ensuring the quality of our database.
You know, they do 4,000 food inspections Thank you.
work on ensuring the quality of our database.
You know, they do 4,000 food inspections, or they oversee 4,000 food establishments that require inspection.
Okay, so they're the ones going out to the restaurants and all looking at the cleanliness of the operation.
Okay, so on line 59, there's an extra $100,000 a year for a full-time temp.
What are we not doing that we need to be doing to bring in a temp?
So there was an LBA audit three years ago, four years ago, just before my time that said that we did not have enough food protection workers.
So this is to add staff to do that.
You guys obviously maintain statistics and benchmarks of how many food, how many inspections of food inspectors should do in a year.
Correct.
And yeah, we have been far below that and really needed some additional staff in order to ensure the safety of our food products in New Hampshire.
And that's why, as a result of that audit and in actuality, that was correct.
So we were able to add.
And then what on line zero, double 007, what is that agency income and what accounts for its growth?
So these are fees for licensing for food establishments.
and I Michelle Robert for licensing for food establishments.
And Michelle Roberge, who's the Bureau Chief for Food Protection, is on.
And Michelle, can you speak to sort of that increase?
Did we increase fees or do we have more establishments that are actually paying those fees?
That might just take a minute.
Oh, there she is.
Okay.
Go ahead, Michelle.
I see Representative Weiler and Norgren.
You'll be next.
Yes, hi.
Michelle Robich.
I'm the Bureau Chief for Public Health Protection.
So as Lisa noted that this program is primarily is an inspection licensing program.
So there are licensing fees.
There are four main sections within this program.
So food protection, beverage and bottled water program, dairy, the dairy program, and the shellfish program.
So those programs issue licenses, and so fees are required as part of that licensure.
And so some of the agency gets income directly.
So the beverage and bottled water program, the dairy program, and a portion of the food safety program, those fees go to a dedicated fund.
The remainder of it, the majority of the fees collected for the food protection program, for the restaurant program, and the shellfish program go to the general fund.
So the fees actually go back to the general fund, and then general funds are given to support the program.
Right.
So here's my general concern and I'd like maybe a written follow-up in this area.
I'm concerned that coming out of the pandemic and the extent to which our restaurant industry has been crushed.
Coming out of it, I'm hesitant to see the state slam restaurant industry has been crushed.
Coming out of it, I'm hesitant to see the state slamming restaurant, and I know it isn't slamming, but from their perspective, it's slamming them with a license fee as they're trying to get back on their feet.
So I'm just wondering if this is something we ought to look at in HB2 to give them some relief for the next couple of years to recover.
And if this is an HB2 item, then I need more information around it so that we write it properly.
So, Representative Edwards, we have this year during the pandemic, which we're currently in, we have this year during the pandemic, which we're currently in, we have wavered and delayed some of these licensing fees in order to help the restaurants.
I do want to say that we rely on these fees for our sustenance for the program.
So it's a fine line to, I totally am with you around you know trying to help them but we would have to figure out how to support the program to ensure that it stays whole.
I am not going to shortchange food protection.
I just want to take a look at these licensing fees because we just declared a whole lot of workers in New Hampshire non-essential.
And now that they're trying to get back on their feet, I just, I want to make it a little easier for them.
So I would like to look at it and I would like to figure out what we need to do to keep this part of the accounts you know sufficiently funded but thank you represent I don't know what you had your hand up first so I'll go with Representative Norgren and then have Representative Weiler back clean up Thank you.
So tell me what the relationship is, and I don't know if it's in this food protection program, what's the relationship with our local health officials?
I mean, most communities have a health official and what would be the relationship?
That's a great question because this particular bureau oversees the health officer program for the state and we do have a very close relationship with them.
We actually have one and a half staff assigned to supporting those health officers and we do have some towns that are are self-inspecting as well.
And we provide training to them and technical assistance and support to them.
Do you have a follow-up to that and take care of your question?
OK, I'm going to assume it did.
Representative Weiler, you're up, sir.
Thank you.
I was involved in that study committee as a result of that audit from a few years ago.
And what we basically were doing was rewriting some of the laws that were declared as being kind of not able to be understood and not able to be properly.
But one of the results of that committee, the FDA throws some money behind this, and they were saying that we don't do enough inspections.
And so our suggestion from the committee, and I think we put it in legislation, but it got defeated by the agency, was you've got hundreds of McDonald's, hundreds of Burger Kings, hundreds of Dunkin' Donuts that get inspected regularly by the franchisor.
And they are far more worried about that inspection than they are about the public health services because they'll just pay the fine.
But if they lose their franchise, they're really in trouble.
So what I suggested and the committee did was that we train those people.
So when they do their franchise inspection, they also have a page that comes from food inspections and they can be doing that inspections as our agents and turning in a report.
But I guess it was fearful of losing a state job that it was defeated.
But it seemed like you could go a long way to fulfilling what the FDA is saying when we only do a third of what they recommend for inspections.
Thank you.
Yes.
So, Representative Waller, so we are currently doing risk-based inspections.
So we have a risk-based approach to how often we inspect these restaurants and food establishments.
I don't think that we were worried about losing positions, I think we're more concerned with ensuring that food inspection is done properly and safely.
And so we continue to take a look at that self-inspection, a trained self-inspection, but currently we're not doing that.
But we continue to use that risk-based inspection approach, and we had to end up doing it that way as a result of the audit, but as a result of just limited capacity to do the level of food inspection that is needed.
But luckily in the last biennium, we were able to get some additional positions.
So to help us with our food establishment inspection.
So thank you.
Is Mr.
Dumont still working there?
No, he's been gone.
No, he's been gone quite a few years now.
He's in Rhode Island.
So what happened to our federal funds?
We went just from $15,000 to basically nothing.
Michelle?
I can answer that.
Oh, OK.
Yeah.
That is, again, an oversight and a mistake that we made using our new source of funds tool.
So we'll be putting in a budget change request to correct that.
Okay, no problem.
Thank you.
All right.
I just want to say something in general to the committee and to the attendees.
You know, everyone from the department to the committee to the LBA staff is really just working a tremendous number of hours these days.
Because on the 24th of March, we have to finish our work on what gets close to being a $6 billion budget for two years with federal and state money included.
And so it isn't just the money, it's these programs affect a tremendous number of lives in New Hampshire.
And I think we're all very sensitive to the impact that these programs have on real people.
And so as we continue to do our work, I just would hope that there would be some level of forbearance and tolerance as we speak amongst ourselves to try to get at what we can do to make these programs as efficient, as effective, and as appropriately resourced as I can, as we can.
So I guess that's just my PR announcement that we just give each other a break as we go through all of this.
And so far, it seems like we have been.
So let's do a time check.
Mr.
Ripple, I have 1110.
I don't think we're going to be able to finish at this rate by, say, 1245.
And I would like a hard start at 130 with our guests.
So do we have a plan B for the spreadsheets we're not doing today?
And if so, what's the plan B?
Yep.
Public health is still scheduled to finish up on Monday if they don't get done today.
So you do have time left over.
Okay.
So I think since I've interrupted everyone's rhythm, let's take a five minute bio break and a little bit of a recess and come back, please.
Thank you.
Yes, I find out the quickest way to unmute yourself is to press the spacebar.
And then when you're through talking, you know, you can't stop.
You don't have to worry about reaching around and finding the button.
That's pretty slick.
I'll try to remember that in my moment of panic next time.
I think we can get started when Mr.
Ripple comes back online.
Yep, you're still recording.
So if everybody's ready, you're good to go.
Okay, so here's my plan.
It's a little past 1115.
I'd like us to find a natural stop point in less than an hour and a half, at which point we'll take our lunch break to 1.30 where we'll have transitioned to some invited guests for this afternoon.
So that's how I think we'll pace it and probably have to continue around B subsequently.
So, all right.
I don't know who was talking and leading, but whoever that is, we can begin again.
It's me again.
All right, we're back.
I think we had finished talking about food protection.
So moving down to 5391 radiological health fees.
Okay, so there's another radiological line elsewhere.
So maybe somebody could just distinguish for me what the general purpose of the radiological health fees are, and then I don't remember where the other radiological activity or work was, but can we parse these out?
Am I wrong?
Is there one or two radiological items?
There's two.
One is radiological emergency preparedness and response, and the other is radiological work relative to inspections of radiological equipment across the state.
And this is the latter, I presume.
Yeah, so fees for, yes, radiological health, that's correct.
This is, so fees are the fees paid by entities who, I don who register or license, I don't know Michelle or Robert can say which one it is, their radiological equipment.
And that's used to support the program.
So I do have just a couple of questions here.
The and 61 that's in 22 and 23 of general funds that I don't know if that's another small mistake or not, but it's.
yeah.
Karen Hollweg, That is that's an error, sir, thank you.
John Potter, Can I ask a question on that.
Yes.
Go ahead.
Is it safe to assume anything under $1,000 in that, that shows up in those kind of places where the other, where previous years had zero, could just, like, just put a zero in there?
I think it is, yeah.
On public health maybe, but not in other areas.
Well, yeah, for public health, yeah.
I can't speak to other areas.
Oh, that, okay.
So the issue is specifically related to public health, this program issue, whatever it was?
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, but I don't know if you can just put a zero there because I'm guessing that that 161 is meant to lay in some other account somewhere and is going to be transferred.
Thank you.
there because I'm guessing that 161 is meant to lay in some other account somewhere and it's going to be transferred.
Exactly.
Yeah, so we'll submit change requests for all of it.
Representative Weiler, do you have a question, sir?
Yes, I do.
When the fees go up on these, which I assume the agency income is the fees for charging people that have an x-ray machine, my dentist has four of them, four operatories.
And he complained one year he had a huge increase in his inspection fees.
And he said in 20 years, it only had two inspections, but he had to mail in an inspection fee every year.
So it looks like we're going up every year on inspection fees.
Why?
Michelle, might you be able to answer that question?
So I can't speak to previous years.
I I know that our fees are established in rule.
So those go through the regulatory process and setting those fees.
Those are for license fees.
So any new pieces of equipment or we have an annual process of renewal.
So they are, you know, subject to submit renewal applications and pay the fee for that.
There is no fee for inspections.
Inspections are done at the frequency is required by NRC.
So depending on the piece of equipment, there's an inspection frequency that the program needs to meet.
And again, that's dependent on the type of device.
We also, so this program regulates machines, radiation machines, like x-ray devices and things like that, and radioactive materials.
So hospitals that use radioactive materials also need to have a license with us as well.
I guess the question was, why do you need to go up every year in the inspection fee or the registration fee?
I would need to verify when the last time we raised our fees.
I'm sorry, I don't have that data in front of me.
And as I said, those fees are established in rules.
So we would have to go through a rulemaking process.
So I don't have the answer for you in terms of when the last time we raised the fees were for this program, but I certainly can find that out for you.
I mean, it may be that there's more equipment being licensed.
We will find that out, but it could relate to more equipment as opposed to more higher fees.
And, you know, these fees are used to support the program as well.
But we'll find that information out for you.
So I'm curious as our medical equipment gets increasingly digitized and self-correcting, if the future of this is going to decline because the calibration and reporting will be automatic and digitized.
So is that theory actually happening in practice?
Are we having to go drive somewhere fewer times because we're getting the same data we need else elsewise so as i'm sorry um as i as i noted the um the inspection frequency for the equipment is is we we try to to meet the guidelines as required by nrc um so our inspectors will go out and take equipment with them to make sure that the device is not emitting higher levels of radiation than it should be.
And so we do a verification process to ensure, again, public health protection, that there isn't excess radiation coming off of these devices.
Sure.
Now, I'm familiar with the 1990s process.
I'm just curious if the technology is getting smart enough to where fewer physical visits are gonna be needed.
I mean, we take our direction from NRC.
So, you know, we can't speak to when their standards will change based upon new technology.
We can move on then.
Representative Irfty, you don't have any questions here, do you?
No, sir.
You don't have any questions here.
I don't think I don't see your hand up.
Correct.
Okay.
I'm going to go ahead and move down then to radiological emergency response.
When was the last time we had a radiological emergency in the state?
I don't know if we've ever had one, but we're prepared in case we ever do.
We work very closely with Homeland Security Emergency Management.
These funds that are here listed the other funds are Seabrook dollars that come in to support this program.
Thank you.
management.
These funds that are here listed, the other funds are Seabrook dollars that come in to support this program.
So Seabrook is required by law to, and the state is required by law to have an emergency response plan that is drilled every so many years.
And as As I say, we work very closely with Homeland Security and Emergency Management on this.
It is a full-time job plus.
Okay, so there's two people doing it now and it's going up to three.
Why do we need to add another person?
I can take that question.
The person was actually previously budgeted in $53.91 and we're moving them into this accounting unit because it's where they belong actually.
So there were three people already doing the program.
Yeah, two of these people are laboratorians who do testing, monitoring, testing on a regular basis.
At Seabrook or elsewhere?
Across the area that Seabrook covers.
Is that a correct statement, Michelle?
You can correct me if I'm wrong.
I'm sorry, Representative Edwards, are you asking where the two positions, the laboratory positions are?
No, I'm asking where do they go out and do testing, and I'm assuming it's at Seabrook, and Ms.
Morris added that it's in the surrounding area where prevailing winds and stuff would maybe cause.
But it's pretty much centered around Seabrook's output.
I would say for the most part, yes.
But there are some baseline locations to make sure that we understand kind of what the baseline levels of radiation, natural radiation are in New Hampshire.
But yes, there is a plethora of monitoring that's done in and around Seabrook Station.
And then I assume you have no vacancies.
Those three positions are currently filled?
That's correct.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, moving down to $53.99, low-level radioactive waste management.
Shelley, is this the...
Yes, I'm seeing revolving funds.
So this is the dedicated fund that we hope to never have to use, which is essentially having to clean up radioactive problems.
Is that correct?
So that's why there's zero expenditures.
We budget just a small amount as a safety.
Michelle, can you speak to this?
Is that a correct statement that Karen made?
Because I know we do do some removal.
Yes, occasionally when the department is notified of, if, you know, sometimes we find these at transfer stations, a low level radioactive waste will show up at a transfer station and it needs to be disposed of it properly.
And so our inspectors will go out and take possession of it and then dispose of it.
And sometimes these funds are used for that purpose.
It's pretty sparingly, but yes, it does happen sometimes.
The next one is 5698, which is lead of poisoning prevention fund.
And what I would mention here is this program had funding added in the last by NEM, if I remember correctly.
It may have been in the next accounting unit, though.
So I don't see any personnel associated with this line.
I believe it's in the next accounting unit and 5964 and lead prevention are the staff.
If I may just add, I'm sorry, that there is a part-time position that we will be, that these funds will support for the, for the lead program and you'll see that in class.
What kind of work will that part-time employee do?
This person is going to help with our environmental investigation team.
So they will be helping coordinate environmental.
So they will be helping coordinate environmental inspections and just coordinating that group.
And as I said, this is a part-time position.
It's more field work than office work.
This position will probably be more office work, but it supports our field team, our field inspection investigation team.
All right.
And the next accounting unit is 7,964, which is lead prevention.
And this is where I mentioned that there were additional funds added in class 102 that would have been higher than what was actually spent there.
I'm sure it took some time to get the contracts in place.
Given that there are 12 permanent classified here, why wouldn't the temporary employee be down in this section of the budgets to keep all the humans together?
Shelley, can you answer that?
Sure.
The temporary position is being funded out of the money that comes into accounting unit 5698, so that's why we put that position in there.
Agency income that comes in and in 7964 lead prevention, it's mostly federal dollars from grants and a little bit of general funds as well.
Thank you.
in and in 79-64 lead prevention it's mostly federal dollars from grants and a little bit of general funds as well.
Representative Waller.
I had a question about the fund mix.
So it looks like our general funds have gone down, not much, but a little bit, a couple hundred thousand.
And it looks like the federal funds have gone up by almost, almost doubled actually from 2020.
And I wondered, is that a new program that the federal government is funding or is it just a formula and we are getting more funds from the federal government than we had previously gotten?
Michelle?
Sure.
So this program is supported by three different grants, one by CDC and two by EPA.
And again, last year, you know, we were intending to apply for a new grant.
And with COVID, they decided to forego the application process.
And we did get extra funds for that grant as well in that year.
But primarily these funds, you know, again, we generally apply for these every five years.
Shelley, I don't know if you can speak any more to the...
I can definitely try.
Something that I've found over my 10 years at public health is that the CDC-led funds seem to fluctuate.
So there'll be a few years where they're pumping out a lot of money to us and we're taking it in and we're running with it.
And then the next couple of years, they'll reduce it significantly.
And then we're struggling to try to cover the activities that we were doing with that extra money.
And then two years later, they're giving us that larger amount as well.
So that may be a little bit of what the fluctuation was in the past.
So the 1.2 we have budgeted right now is what we're anticipating based on what we've been communicated to by the federal funders.
Thank you.
Sure.
So I'm not certain on, I'd have to go back to the program manager and check and get back to you.
Thank you.
Sure.
So I'm looking at line 50, personal service temp appointee.
Is this, this implies another person or more hours?
What's going on in this line?
So there are two part-time positions as well in this AU, along with 12 class-10 positions.
Are you adding one, though, in this next budget?
you I'm just looking at the jump in the number and it looks like you're either adding a person or you're increasing some hours no we aren't adding and where do you see where do you see that representative edwards can you point to that yes ma'am i'm looking at line 50, personal service temp slash appointee.
And so in the current budget year, we're spending about $40,000 each year.
And in the next budget, we're spending about $68,000.
So going from $40,000 to $68,000 feels to me like we're adding man hours or manpower.
So I can say that we are gearing up.
So over the past, since 2019, the blood lead action level in the state is lowering.
And so in 2019, it went from 10 micrograms per deciliter to seven and a half.
And then it's going to lower again in 2021 to five.
And so we're anticipating an increase in workload significantly in this program.
So I know that we are working hard to fill any vacancies that we have in anticipation for the increase in workload.
Okay, so that addresses that question.
So of the 12, how many of those are vacant currently?
You think?
Of the 12, we have one vacancy that we are recruiting for.
Thank you.
that we are recruiting for.
What kind of person are you hiring here?
And by that, I mean academic or experiential background.
So this position that we're recruiting for is a public health nurse to help with our nurse case management for children who have elevated blood lead levels.
Are there any other questions here?
I don't see any.
Moving down to 79.36 is climate change adaptation.
I have a question about that.
Go ahead.
What is it?
Michelle, do you want to talk about climate change?
Sure.
So the climate and health program in New Hampshire, this is a federal grant from CDC supports this program.
This program is really just one staff person.
And you'll see in class 10 that this there looks like there was an increase, but this position was paid in a different accounting unit and is transferred over to this accounting unit.
I'm actually asking about the money.
What do they do?
Oh, sorry.
So basically they take federal funds and invest them into straightforward public health actions to improve community health.
We use CDC's what's called the BRACE format, which is really just building greater workforce capacity to address climate change via engagement and training.
I definitely want to hear the verbiage.
I want to know exactly what do you mean when you say those words.
Give an example of what something you're doing that's affecting climate change.
Sure.
So the whole main purpose of the program is really about adaptation.
It's helping communities adapt to the issues around climate change.
Michelle, yeah, I'll try.
So, for example, with warmer climates, we're getting more Lyme disease.
So we may provide grants to regions to be able to do training for children around Lyme disease prevention or tick prevention services.
For other regions, we may provide interventions or funding for them to deal with older adults and heat issues.
So those are just two examples of the way that we use those dollars.
It's really very public health focused around warmer climate issues.
Representative Weiler, do you have a question, sir?
I just don't think it's a worthwhile program.
There's nothing we can do about climate change and wasting a lot of money trying to do something.
Representative Weiler, this isn't about what we do has nothing to do with adapting climate.
It really has to do with helping people to ensure their health as climate warms.
You're right, there's nothing, we're not debating whether or not climate, you know, we're doing anything about climate change.
It's really about those impacts on individual health that we're trying to impact.
Well, I think every summer we have people that get heat stroke and get adverse reactions to the heat.
And I don't think we need to label that as something different.
It's something you've always done anyway.
If I could, I would suggest that the scope of our committee is to look at the financial aspect and not the policy that's federal and state.
I think from a financial policy perspective, given these are federal funds, I would just ask, why is this a permanent classified position and not temporary?
Because we can fund it as long as there's federal money.
Shelly, can you speak to why positions may go from temporary to permanent or Karen, either way.
If a position goes from temporary to permanent it's because it's been converted, which does require approval during the governor's phase of the budget.
So this may have happened, you know, quite a while ago.
Last, this current budget, there were zero people, and now there's one projected.
So just looking at the paper, it looks like this is a new position, and we've decided to make it permanent to begin with.
And that's what I'm looking at.
This position, we first got the climate grant, like 2012 perhaps, have a position for it, and we've had the position ongoing.
The last biennium, the grant was the scope or the activities of the grant were such that they wanted to put most of the money out into contracts.
And the position was then moved over into the preventive health block grant to continue to help that with that work.
In this new biennium, 22-23, the grant is now affording the position.
So we are moving it back in here.
OK.
So I just would note that it appears that the major change in the next budget is that less money is actually going for the programs, a significant amount less.
And from what I'm looking at, we went from zero to one permanent employee.
And so even though it's federal money, it just doesn't look to me like, it doesn't feel to me like managing this very well.
That's the wrong way to just be spending money on permanent employees and less money on programs.
I don't know that we're doing anybody any good that way.
And then that's, there's not a question in there.
That's just a comment.
Representative Weiler, sir, I apologize.
I think I may have cut you off and you still, do you have something more you'd like to say, sir?
No problem.
All right.
So let's continue.
Okay.
The next accounting unit is 7426, which is EPH tracking.
This is environmental public health tracking.
Thank you.
Good thing.
Which public health thing are we tracking?
Environmental contamination, for example.
We track that relative to health impacts.
Lead is covered somewhere else.
And so I'm just curious what other environmental factors we're monitoring.
So this particular program works with all the other programs across the division and with Department of Environmental Services to be able to track the variety of environmental contaminants such as lead as an example, PFAS as an example, to be able to track the variety of environmental contaminants such as lead as an example, PFAS as an example, to be able to sort of figure out where in this arsenic, another example, to figure out where in the state we have high levels so we can target interventions, where we have the resources to do so.
So that's part of what they do.
So we've got federal funding only.
We've got permanent classified positions and we're growing the permanent classified position from two to three.
And so similar conversations we just had, why are we adding a person?
What will that person do?
And why aren't these temporary positions since they're reliant on federal funding?
Michelle, can you speak to, are we adding positions in this program?
looks like we are.
So we moved a position.
We moved an existing position into this program to support.
We received, well, the Department of Environmental Services received a new federal grant called the Appletree Grant.
And so we're a partner with them.
And so this position, which was in, I believe it was in the block grant, was moved to this accounting unit because its primary function will be to, you know, work on the Apple Tree program within this accounting unit.
And I can give you more information on the Apple Tree if you'd like.
That's where you'll see some of the differences in this account are the are the funding that we received as part of that apple tree program yeah i think we're just finding a couple of areas here where we have fundamentally different management philosophy between the department and my own personal view and that is if something's 100% funded by federal money and we can't control how much they give us, that it doesn't do our people any good to put them into permanent positions that may actually be temporary.
And it just seems to me like we're not using the system properly.
But we can take that offline, I guess, because it's not worth belaboring in public.
We can go on to the next one if there are no questions.
Okay.
That, I believe, concludes the Bureau of Public Health Protection.
Thank you, Michelle, very much.
Moving on to the Bureau of Community and Health Services, I believe is what the CLM is there.
Accounting unit 0836, an elusive three-digit accounting number.
It's like seeing license plates that start with zeros.
0836 is pregnancy risk monitoring system.
Okay.
What is a pregnancy risk monitoring service?
I just, I know what each of the words means.
I just am not sure what it means all put together.
I can take this one, Lisa.
So we call this PRAMS because public health loves a good acronym.
And this is a survey that we received federal funding, CDC funding to do to better understand the pregnancy and birth experience of women in New Hampshire.
It is a survey that is done nationally, so we can benchmark those health outcomes and those experiences with the experiences of others in other states.
So this is places where we understand if women are drinking alcohol or while pregnant.
We also understand sort of birth weight.
We also can put together information around that to do the data analysis to better understand how we can support that cohort of women.
Okay, thank you for that.
And so just I guess this is going to be lumped into the same bucket of conversation around the use of permanent classified positions to fund positions that are 100% federally funded.
So I think we just have a misalignment of our manpower resources.
And then I'm looking at what we do.
And then I noticed that there's on line 50, we have, it looks like we're increasing man hours or manpower.
What are we doing in the next budget on 50?
Cy, we have Dr.
Cy Charella who is available to answer questions relative to the community population health bureau.
Cy, can you respond to that question?
Can you let somebody let Cy Torella in?
Kevin did.
I think she's in.
Oh, great.
Cy?
Maybe she isn't.
Hold on one second.
I'm here.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Thank you.
Dr.
Torella, thank you for joining us.
You must be very busy.
Thank you so much, Representative Edwards.
I know the question about the personal service, the line 050 class line.
We also have a part-time position in this AU, and that part-time position actually helps with interning the moms when we provide the survey.
So that is that person.
And actually, because we are getting some additional funds to support COVID-related surveys, so those are the additional dollars we are adding to that.
That explains the increase in federal funds because you're going to get a COVID plus up?
Yes.
So the extra manpower is going to be used then to do that extra work.
That makes 100% sense, even to me as a non-physician.
Okay.
And then I don't know if you want to speak to the federal funds issue, funding a permanent classified position versus a temporary position.
I can jump in there.
So there are many places throughout the department, not just in public health, where there are permanent positions that are associated with federal funds.
We do try to limit when we do that, when it is federal funding that is less guaranteed, if you will.
So when it comes to block grants that have been in place for 20 years, we don't have a lot of concern around that, you know, sort of just going away.
But some of the smaller, more infrequent grants, we try not to associate permanent positions with them.
What I would say is that just like a temporary position, if the funding goes away for a position, the result is the same at the end, which is that the person doesn't have a position any longer.
You would have to lay that person off or have them apply to a different position in the department, but the end result is generally the same when it comes to funding no longer existing.
So you're teaching me a very specific thing, I think.
And I'm laboring under the assumption that a person holding a temporary position has a different layoff procedure than somebody in a permanent classified position would.
That the permanent classified would kind of, I'm not using the right words, but would have a higher level of protection or process than a temporary person would.
So a temporary position does have an end date on it.
So that is one difference that if the temporary position ends, that ends the position, where a permanent position does not have an end date.
So that is certainly one of the larger differences.
There are certainly layoff procedures when it comes to permanent positions, and I do not oversee HR, so I don't want to pretend to know those rules or the union rules associated with when we can lay off an employee.
But if the funding no longer exists, we have to level set our budget to adjust for that.
And so just to be clear for the attendees that are listening in, I fully support the idea of having a pregnancy risk monitoring system.
Good, I can move on to accounting in 1844, which is teen pregnancy prevention.
No, I just, I need to make a comment here.
Okay.
So, I support having a pregnancy risk monitoring system, but I also want to be careful that we don't bind future legislatures to decisions that we make today.
And that's why I've been talking about whether these positions should be permanent or temporary.
And it should not be considered to be disparaging towards the value and benefit of the program.
It's simply a financial conversation around the right way to structure an organization.
It's a good program.
I support it.
I just want to make sure that we have the right administrative systems around the DHHS.
So we can go on.
Okay.
What I would mention is if there was a decision to eliminate this permanent position and make it a temporary position, I do believe that the person would have to reapply for the position.
I would have to talk to personnel, but I don't think we can just move them to a different position, just so you're aware.
Okay, the next accounting is is 1840-14 Pregnancy Prevention.
And this is one of those accounting units which we've talked about before where we're moving the expenditure from class line 102 to 74.
Are there any questions here?
Okay, the next accounting unit is 2207, which is WIC food rebates.
So this is all, I'm assuming this is all federal, WIC.
I'm behind you on the slide.
It is all federal, yes.
Is that correct?
It's private local.
Does that mean federal?
Oh, okay.
This is food rebates.
Okay.
I apologize.
Dr.
Turella, would you like to respond?
Yeah, sure.
The food rebates is basically we have, we get food rebates from food companies, especially the baby food formula.
We receive the revenue from the winning contractor, so they provide a rebate on all our standard milk and soya infant formula, and this revenue is actually used to, again, support our additional WIC families.
It's required that all these rebates ones should go to the food costs, not for any programming or any other things.
So from our actual, in FY20, we're assuming another, you know, jump to 22, 23.
What would account for that extra flow of income?
Are we charging or are we asking for a higher rebate?
Are we expecting more baby food to be sold?
What's going on there?
We're expecting again with the COVID impact with the food insecurity, we are expecting that there will be an increased use or increased need.
So that's where we have additional funds.
And there are very specific provisions in statute that don't allow us to spend more than we receive.
So if we, I'm guessing that in 2020, that was also budgeted at 4 million and we only received 2.7 million.
So we only spent 2.7 million.
All right, thank you.
We can go to the next.
Moving down to a 2215 CDC oral health grant.
This is a 10017,000 $17,000 $17,000 $17,000 $17,000 $17,000 $17,000 $17,000 $17,000 $17,000 $17,000 $17,000 $ Okay, so what is the nature of these contracts?
What are we contracting for?
So basically this one, thank you for the question, Representative.
Our focus is especially providing oral health programs for the school-based clinics as well as our community-based clinics.
So school-based clinics is more focused on for all the low-income children as well as for the community-based, again, low-income adults we focus on.
So our idea is to, our focus is to reduce the dental caries and improve the oral health.
So that's where our, most of our contracts go in to support those agencies.
Right.
So, so we're doing adult care in here.
It sounds like, yes.
Yes, for the, some of our community-based agencies do support our low-income adults.
So, just so you know what I'm thinking is that if we do start up the Medicaid dental program, I'm just curious how this program and the Medicaid dental program would work collaboratively to create a community-based solution that's evidence-based.
We have been working with our Medicaid program on that topic.
We have partnership in understanding how we address those things.
And we are working towards understanding what the population needs are and all those things.
All right.
Very good.
Are there any other questions here?
Thank you.
Okay.
Next is 4526 MCH data linkage.
That's maternal and child health.
Thank you.
Okay.
The next one is 4527, which is oral health capacity, rural health.
So I assume this is doing something to make sure that we have dentists out in the rural areas.
Is that what this is doing?
Yes, this is a combination of a couple of funding sources.
We have federal funds from the HRSA, as well as some of our general funds.
Our focus is very much on improving the capacity, the overall health capacity, as well as providing some training to our dental providers on some of the opioid prescription.
Those are some of the things that we are working towards.
So how do we do that?
Do we target higher reimbursements with this fund so that dentists have a greater financial incentive to serve in that area?
Or do we do direct payments for locations?
Or how do we decide which dentists get it and which don't?
We actually look at health service shortage areas.
So we call it dental professional shortage areas.
So we look at those areas within our state to target those services.
So if they're in a specific geographic location, then we pay them a supplement.
And if they're not in that geographic location, they don't get the supplement.
Is that basically how that program works?
We haven't, I mean, this is not like a whole statewide program.
It's very specific communities kind of thing.
So that's where we focus in those dental professional shortage areas.
We focus to support some of their, as I mentioned before, those community-based and school-based services, we based on the base for those areas too.
So they get a percentage of time of the dental provider is provided to do this contract.
Dr.
Torella, are these providers often connected to a community health center?
Yes, some of them are connected to community health centers.
Some of them are connected to the school, school health services.
So that's how we provide those support services.
Representative Irf, do you have a question?
Just a quick one.
Any reason that the federal funds went away this year and they bounced, whether they were there before and they come back next year?
I'm sorry, I didn't understand your question.
Sorry, you're presenting there.
So the FY21 adjusted authorized budget, unless I'm being in the wrong place.
Which one are we on?
It doesn't have any federal funds.
Shelly, can you speak to that?
I can, yes.
Before, well, currently in 2021, this grant was actually mixed in with the other accounting unit, 2215.
And so we're pulling it out and putting it back over here.
Previous, this accounting unit, even though it was called rural health, I don't know why it got budgeted incorrectly historically, but it only had general funds tied to it.
Although it shows general funds for 20 actual.
Yes, we have.
I mean, federal funds.
Yes, we, yes.
So federal, no federal, federal.
So, Shelly, are we going to fiscal committee to adjust the federal funds for fiscal year 21 there?
I'd have to check on that.
It's not in my memory bank at the moment.
I'm sorry.
No problem.
So I'm just looking at an efficiency angle here i i i still don't know which dentists get money and which don't on what basis but but to shift it a little bit it it looks like uh 20 percent of the money spent in this program goes to a state employee and 80% to actual providers.
And so my question is, does that, does that, is, is that perceived to be an efficient program?
We think so.
We think it's an efficient program.
And, you know, these providers are in communities where there are low income individuals and partners that that that is a part of their mission is to serve low income individuals.
So you need somebody to manage these these various contracts that go along with this pot of money.
And if I can just add a little bit here to your point that you've made several times around is this effective use of funds, we can say that certainly those school-based dental clinics in those rural areas, we can show over time that where we've invested in that school-based dental clinic, the number of caries in that population, the number of cavities in those kids has dramatically declined.
It's one of the great places where we can see investment goes up.
When the investment goes up, the caries go down.
And we know that that saves money all around and improves health outcomes.
That's outstanding.
Thank you.
Representative Edwards, I just know the time because you were concerned about that.
I am.
Am I asking too many questions, Representative Irv?
No, no, no.
It's after 12.
I thought you had mentioned 12.
That's all.
No, I had mentioned going between 1230 and 1245 is what I meant to say.
That would give us our 45 minutes.
Sorry.
That's all right.
Are there any other questions here?
Okay.
Thank you.
We could go on.
All right.
12 to 10 people working in this area.
Is that just a transfer of positions or is that because of the workload is going down or what's happening?
We move positions into other accounting units to better align with the programs.
Generally, what kind of skill set do the remaining 10 have?
Are they nurse practitioners of some kind?
Or what are they?
Go ahead, Sai, go ahead, Sai.
Go ahead, Lisa.
No, you go.
I was going to ask you to go.
Go ahead.
Thank you for the question, Representative Edwards.
Many of them are nurses.
Some of them are public health specialists focused on specific programs.
So we have a combination of clinically trained as well as public health trained staff in these positions.
And just by way of background, this particular accounting unit 5190 was historically where all maternal and child health programs were located.
And over the course of many bienniums now we have tried to appropriately put when we've had federal programs put them in their own accounting units so it's a it's it has scaled down in some capacities it's scaled up and down but we're trying to more appropriately align the budgets now.
Representative Walner, you have your hand up.
Yes, thank you, Chairman Edwards.
So in 2021, I see under contracts you were authorized for over $5 million in contracts, which was almost $2 million more than in 2020, which you spent.
I wondered what was it that you were proposing to do in 2021 that didn't happen?
Dr.
Torella?
I think some of that too before she speaks is moving some of that into class line 74.
There's about 850,000 that's been moved to 74 as well.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Is there anything that you did request in 2021 that is not in 2022?
No.
What we have requested is still there.
Only the contract line has, as Karen mentioned, it's just got adjusted between class 102 and 074.
In this area, is the budget that the governor is proposing meet with what the department requested of the governor?
No, not in this EU.
No, I think the question is, so this is not where our prioritized need is identified.
Is that correct?
It's a different accounting unit.
Yes, that's right.
So yes, it is what we requested.
It is what you requested.
Thank you.
On the line item you just pointed out, 74 grants for public assistance and relief.
Yes.
What is this?
It seems like this is a complimentary program that supplements other programs.
Are you sure it's not a redundant program?
So can you talk about what the focus of this program is?
Sure.
I think probably Karen or Shelly can talk about what the 074 line is.
But overall, the MCH, the block, we call it block grant, MCH block grant, Title V.
It's a key source of supporting and promoting improving health and well-being of moms and children, basically, and also children with special needs and their families.
And it actually supports our infrastructure for almost our 15 community health centers, also supports some of our injury prevention work through our contact with the Injury Prevention Center, as well as some of our injury prevention activities around, for example, the Brain Injury Association, the Traumatic Brain Injury.
Those are some overview big items.
Our primary care contact specifically focuses on low-income population and enabling services for them.
So this includes supporting some of their community navigation or clinical navigation programs, supporting some of their behavioral health needs, as well as supporting them for their language, because some of them have a different need in the language.
So those are some overview of what services we provide to our MCH block network.
All right.
So you mentioned translation services.
I know that in the refugee area we have translation services.
So I'm curious if we've got a complimentary program at that level or is it redundant?
It's probably not a huge part of this spend though.
No, it's not a huge part of spend, but the language translation is more for the community health centers.
So it supports some of their services in that area.
I think it's a complimentary in many ways, but this is very much focused at the clinical system level.
It oftentimes is a gap-filling service.
Again, with our federally qualified health centers, although we've made tremendous strides with Medicaid, especially for children and adults, we still have uninsured individuals.
And so sometimes it can fill some of those things like translation for those uninsured individuals.
Are there any other questions?
I'm ready to go to the next.
Okay.
5240 is newborn screening revolving.
Karen, just to give you a heads up, in about 15 minutes, I'm going to ask you for your best estimate for how much time is needed to complete this.
So before we break huddle today, I'm just going to be curious how much more time we're going to need when we do phase B.
Okay.
I will think about it and be prepared for your question.
Newborn screening revolving fund.
Where is the money coming from to Revolve?
That's a very good, interesting question, Representative Edwards.
This is actually, it's a revolving fund.
It's funded by filter paper fees, and those are actually paid by our hospitals and our healthcare providers as well as our birthing centers.
So that's, the filter paper is basically, that's how we actually test for the newborn.
We take a prick of their feet to get the blood and that blood is tested for almost 37 birth conditions.
So to understand what's happening on, like if they have any kind of specific metabolic disorders.
And that information comes to us.
And based on that, we follow with the pediatric providers and others.
So the blood goes on to the filter papers, correct?
So this is what HB 600 is intended to influence?
Yes, that's right.
Okay, so if we pass HB 600, if it were to pass, what is the impact on this line item?
Will the source of the money just change or will this line diminish?
Or what is the impact in this area should that bill get passed?
If that bill gets passed, we don't see an impact on our program.
But on the behind the scenes, the hospitals, how they actually bill for the filter paper would change.
So they would be able to get more, they would be able to get the rates on the filter paper, specifically from insurance providers.
So I'm a simple guy.
So what I think I just heard you say is the insurance companies will pay more, the hospitals will pay less and therefore be a little better off, and the state remains the same.
Yes.
That's in shock, yes.
Our hope is that.
Thank you.
Okay, any other questions on 5240?
I don't see any.
Moving down to 5260 WIC Supplemental Nutrition Program.
So this is the program itself.
This obviously has a large amount being transferred to 74.
Do we think we're going to spend that $10 million in federal money for FY21 adjusted?
Or are we not going to spend that?
I'm talking about the federal funds line for WIC supplemental.
Yeah, anticipating that we will be able to spend all those dollars.
Again, with the food insecurity and COVID, we are getting more federal funds.
but we also see there will be an anticipated need going forward after we come down from the fact of COVID.
So there's going to be more follow-up that's going to happen.
So we expect that we'll be able to spend those dollars.
I think Chris Santanello spoke to earlier that there's been an increase in food stamps and so that has been affecting our other programs like WIC.
So once that increase is no longer available, we probably will see an increase here again.
Okay.
The next accounting unit is 5330, which is family planning program.
And I'm going to go ahead and preempt a couple of questions that I know exist here.
So, Representative Walner, the governor's budget here does not reflect the agency request.
The reason for that is during the governor's phase, an adjustment was made to reduce the general funds and increase the federal funds.
Now, the increase in federal funds should not have happened.
So let me go through what the intent was and why I, quite frankly, was the one that advised that.
increase in federal funds should not have happened.
So let me go through what the intent was and why I, quite frankly, was the one that advised that made that mistake.
So during the 2021 biennium, there was a change to the Title X rules, laws.
I wouldn't invite program to jump in if I say any of this incorrectly, but there was a change to the laws that reduced the funds that went from the federal government directly to some of our providers.
So during the legislative phase of preparing for the 2021 budget, the House committee, your committee, added more general funds to this budget to essentially supplant the federal funds that those agencies were no longer receiving.
So those federal funds did not flow through the department previously, and those general funds were intended to supplant something that didn't flow through us.
It is anticipated, although not yet official or changed, that the, or this is the governor's office assumption, that the Title X rules will change again to go back to where they were, previous bienniums, and that those federal funds will again flow directly to some of our providers.
And so that the general fund supplanting will no longer be necessary.
And so that is the change that was made in the governor's phase.
As I mentioned, I incorrectly told them that it would be federal funds flowing through us.
Those federal funds would not flow through us.
So I would be submitting a change request to reduce the federal funds in this accounting unit.
But the general funds are also lower for that reason.
Is there anything I missed there, Lisa or Trish?
And explaining- You did very well.
Okay, once in a while.
while under wall or you'll have a follow-up when they're ready i'm i'm good i think we're good for questions okay i may have to i may have to play that over again in my head for a little while because it was quite a um so what I'm wondering, so you're going to come back to us, Karen, do I understand this right that you are coming back to us with a reduced federal funding level here?
Yes, because the federal funds should be more in line with where they are in fiscal year 21 in that $1.2 million range, not $2.1 million, because those federal funds that the general funds were supplanting in 2021 are federal funds that would flow directly from the federal government.
So they would not go through DHHS.
So we're dependent for all of this to happen on something that's going to happen in Washington to change the way they fund family planning.
do we have a date when all of this is going to actually happen or is this just out in the future someplace?
Representative Walner, we have been told it's expected within between six months and a year that that change will take place.
The fiscal year for the federal government starts one October, which could leave a three-month gap.
I think.
Six months to a year from now?
Yes.
Or...
Okay, so the $811,000 on that line will be considerably short.
it looks like there had been it looked like they were trying I thought that what had happened is we were trying to bring in more federal funds to replace general funds.
But that doesn't seem that doesn't seem what it is at all.
Doesn't seem like there will be more general funds.
So the 811 is considerably short from previous budgets.
So in previous budgets, like 2020, it was $1.4 million.
So that's several hundred thousands of dollars less.
how do we figure this so that we have the right amount of funding on these lines?
So are you asking how do we determine the amount of general funds that should supplant the federal funds?
Yes.
Yeah, I think that does depend on when that rule change does happen.
So we could probably provide you like the amount for a six month cost if that's helpful.
Or a three month cost or a year cost, but whatever the request is we can provide the amount.
I think you probably should give it to us in three months so we know know what a three month wedge would be because I'm anticipating that we might need a bridge from July one our fiscal year to October one the federal fiscal year.
We can provide that.
Okay, for you.
Representative Walner, you still have the floor, maam go ahead the floor um so is there a federal match requirement of the states for these funds yes and that is what that 811 000 in general funds is there is the state match but what was it matching was it matching 2 million?
It's matching the, no, it's matching around 1.2 million.
Okay.
I look forward to seeing the additional materials you're going to provide to us.
Thank you.
So you know what might be helpful, Representative Walner, if you would consider writing down exactly what you're thinking in this area and if you want to send it directly to the department so that they're clear on what your questions and concerns are.
Yeah.
I don't think the whole committee needs to be involved in that dialogue at this point.
Thank you.
I will do that.
I will send it directly to Karen.
Thank you.
And then, so we've got a couple of representatives ready to go.
I just wanted to clarify something I thought I heard.
It sounded to me like some of these federal funds in the future had all been expected to come through DHHS, but that assumption is no longer accurate.
So my clarification question is, is that because some amount of the money we were expecting to come to DHHS might flow directly to health providers and bypass the state?
No, we were never expecting it to come through DHHS.
Karen Rounds misunderstood and screwed it up.
Quite frankly, that's really all it was.
I misunderstood how the program worked and the federal funds have never come through the department.
The federal funds that we have been supplanting with general funds in 2021 have never come through the department and are never anticipated to.
So it was a massive screw up.
Totally massive screw up.
Yeah, I have those sometimes regularly, sometimes not.
You never know.
Yeah.
Yep.
So that was all mine to own.
Okay.
So Representative Rogers.
Do we know, are the providers going to be able to hang on for three months?
and what of population is not going to be served with health care during this time if they don't, if they're going from in excess of $2 million or $3.4 million that they got to 800,000.
And if it goes three months is one question you said up to a year, what's the danger of any of these providers closing their doors?
And do we know how many people are gonna be going without healthcare?
I remember from the budget two years ago that some of these providers are the only providers of healthcare to certain amounts of the population.
I mean, if...
member from the budget two years ago that some of these providers are the only providers of health care to certain amounts of the population.
I mean, if we don't have the general funds to support those providers while we're waiting for that rule change, then, you know, we'll have to figure out how to use those.
I'm not sure what we will do.
Was there a request made for a larger amount of general funds from the governor's office?
Yes, the agency budget had those general funds in it.
Okay, and that's part of the information I presume you'll be getting to Representative Walner.
To clarify what you said, Chair, it sounded like you wanted part of the information though for the whole committee.
You're just saying that some of them were in-depth information?
I'm saying Representative Waller has a deeper set of questions than what we need for the committee.
What I think the committee need for information here is, as I'm keeping mental track, is that we need to, I guess I still need to understand what the wedge would be to get us from July 1 to October 1, assuming that the federal funds are going to pick up again.
But now, Ms.
Rounds, I got to admit I'm thoroughly confused because there have been federal funds in the past.
Where did they go?
And, you know, and where do we expect them to come?
They went somewhere.
So right now, the majority of the family planning providers are not, some of the family planning providers are not able to participate in the Title X program, which is what these federal funds are.
So they have been receiving general funds instead to continue their programs.
So the federal funds are used to support the state staff and the services on the state side, but we are also putting out RFP for those Title 10 funds as we speak.
But they have to be accounted for somewhere.
And I thought I heard Ms.
Brown say that the accounting for them on this line item 000 federal funds is not as accurate as she wants it to be correct this 2.1 million dollar number is too high it should be closer to this 1.2 of fiscal year 21 you're assuming 1.2 more on maintenance of the federal status quo and not a projection of them increasing the reimbursement because of the change in Title X.
Correct.
The state won't receive any increase in its federal funding because of the change in Title X.
If they change it back, we would.
No.
Some of our providers would receive additional federal funds directly from the federal government.
Oh, see, I explicitly try to ask that question.
If any of this money that's going to be increased bypasses the state and goes directly to the providers, when I asked that, I was told no.
No, we contract with these providers for those dollars.
So we have the dollars, we contract with providers.
And then there are other Title 10 funds the department is not involved with that go directly to the federal.
When we do the contract, the money goes straight from the federal government to the provider bypassing the state?
No, we don't have any involvement in those funds, in those federal funds.
We don't contract for them.
We don't tell the agencies what they can do with them.
That's between them and the federal government.
So there are providers in New Hampshire that are expecting to get an increase in federal funds in the coming years.
Potentially, if the rule changes again.
If the rule changes.
All right.
I think I understand.
I'm a little slow, but okay.
Representative Rogers, you actually have the floor still.
Go ahead.
I just asked one last follow-up.
Could you tell me what the original agency request was for the state general funding on this?
Shelley, do you have that, Andy?
It would be the $811,000 plus $1.6 million in general.
Plus $1 million?
$1.6 million.
Okay, okay, I was wondering.
Plus the 811, okay.
And that was what the original request went to the governor with.
Okay, thank you very much.
That's it.
Do you have any other follow-ups for Representative Rogers?
No, thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, call my name.
It's really hard to hear you sometimes, Jess.
Oh, I'm sorry, Representative Irf.
Thank you.
I'm fading.
I'm going to need a sandwich soon.
Karen, can I get a list of all of the providers in the current biennium that I'm contracted with, and the total funds, and then a breakdown of general and federal funds?
Yes, actually, I did provide that to the LBA already, I think, for the chair.
So they should have that information.
I will make a note.
I think I have that, Representative Irf.
I'll forward it to you.
Okay, so that's separate from the list of things on the website, Kevin?
It is, yes.
Okay, thank you.
So, as long as...
Go ahead.
The only reason I asked the question earlier about what you were looking for for the committee is just so...
So when Jonah's list comes to me, I make sure that we're providing the right information for the whole committee.
I appreciate that.
And I'm also attempting to simultaneously be sensitive to the idea, the potential, that Representative Walner has questions that she would like direct answers to and not share necessarily at this point with the committee.
I don't know if that's true or not, but I just allow for the possibility.
So OK, I have a question.
In FY19, which you're probably not prepared to answer, what was the general fund level for this activity code in FY19?
I'm looking to Shelly.
It looks like she might be looking that up for you.
I would say it's around the $800,000 mark because our match is close to $800,000 for our federal dollars.
Could you verify that and share that with us and put it on Jonah's list of questions, please?
Sure.
Representative Norgren?
Thank you Mr.
Chair.
I'm concerned if we have the department communicating with only one or two members of the committee in whatever requests they have.
Could you please make sure we all receive the same information so so yes but no representative nordgren i i i don't know if representative walner wants to ask questions that she is interested in sharing with the committee at this point in time so i'll just let her speak to that do Do you want to do that?
Or I'm allowing, I'm trying to create a channel for you to have some privacy in your communication.
No, any questions that I have, I would want the whole committee to have the answers.
I'm not going to be, there's no information here that I wouldn't want everyone to have.
So I think actually I'm getting most of my questions answered at this point.
Thank you.
Okay, so in that case, you know, make sure you send them to Mr.
Ripple and then he'll coordinate.
Okay.
All right.
I thought you might have had a special need there that I was hoping to satisfy with you.
Mr.
Chair, there have been other instances where other members of the committee have said they requested information sent to them.
Can we please make sure Mr.
Ripple gets copies of that so we can all see the same information.
I think so.
I believe I've asked once or twice for information to help me with some special projects.
And then I did that directly and have not shared the results, mostly because I didn't think it would interest anyone but me.
But if that's what you're referring to, I can go back through my email and figure out what I might have asked for.
Is that what you're talking about?
Yeah, well, I think just going forward, as we start getting down and making decisions, I think we just all need the same information.
That's fine.
Thank you.
Okay, very good.
Are there any other questions?
So we've really spent a lot of time on this.
It's an important topic.
I think this is as good a time as any to go ahead and break for lunch.
So Ms.
Rounds, now's the time for the question.
Based on what we have to go and based on what we've done so far, what do you think our time estimate is?
So based on conferring with Shelly, I think, or Rochelle, that we're probably less than 90 minutes.
So we were on page like Thank you.
Based on conferring with Shelly, I think, or Rochelle, that we're probably less than 90 minutes.
So we were on page like 1045 or so, and it goes to 1097.
So I think about an hour and a half to finish out the accounting units.
Mr.
Riple, remind me when we're going to do the phase B of this.
You have public health scheduled for Monday morning.
So join us on Monday morning from the department.
Yes.
Okay.
I'm seeing Trish nod her head yes.
I know it was scheduled on the calendar, so I believe that they all had the time held um could it be 9 30 i know some mondays you have an another conflict um i i i figured out how to work through the conflict so if it's on the house calendar for 9 30 9 30 it is i'll be there great All right.
Well, Dr.
Turella, thank you for joining us.
I really am uncomfortable bringing a physician into this level of detail on finances, but thank you for the answers you provided to us today.
I'll be joining back on March 15th.
Oh, it's that exciting to you.
Good.
Very exciting.
All right.
OK, well, if you could put us on recess and stop recording till 1.30, that'd be great, Kevin.
OK.
Give it a couple of minutes since we have three representatives away.
Two representatives.
Except I'm not seeing Sharon.
Is Sharon out there?
Did she log off?
Because I would think I'd see her if she just turned off her video.
Yeah, it looks like she logged off.
Okay, so you have your you've got the recording turned on.
It's now 1.31.
We just finished our lunch recess.
And we have a quorum of Division III back.
Our first, okay, so what are we doing?
Over the course of the next hour and a half or so, the committee members have been encouraged to invite people in to talk on very specific subjects related to our decisions to help us make our decisions for funding the Department of Health and Human Services or the Veterans Home.
And this is another way in which we're trying to encourage public input into our process.
Normally, in a typical year without a pandemic, we would be having these in a public setting and people could come in and go.
And I understand it was more of a free-flowing involvement of the public that Zoom has truncated a bit for us.
So we've been trying to let people in.
I'll be with you in a second, Representative Warmer.
And during the end of our regular meetings And then today is just another way of getting public input.
Representative Weiler, do you have a question, sir?
I'm trying to start my video and it said you cannot start your video because the host has stopped it.
Well, I don't think we did that on purpose, but let me see if I can fix it.
It was in a different computer, so that's probably good.
I haven't used this one before, and the experts set it up for me, so I don't know what's going on.
There you go.
Thank you.
I don't know what's going on.
There you go.
Okay, there you are.
All right, so with that in mind, we have a number of speakers.
We gave each a request to plan on having a nice, tight presentation, no greater than 10 minutes.
I don't think we're going to have to manage that strictly, but that is our objective.
So with that, if you could bring in our first speaker, Granite Case Management.
Can you do that, Kevin?
Yes.
And I'm going to turn off my video because I haven't finished my lunch and no one wants to see that.
So, Granite State case management is Senator Clegg and Carolyn Virtue, I believe.
You're on mute right now.
There you go.
You are.
You can speak.
Do you have a presentation?
I think as a panelist, you can share your screen.
Do you see the share your screen button?
I don't, but...
And then Mr.
Ripple, I think they sent a copy to the LBA.
I don't know if you...
We sent a copy of the presentation to the LBA.
That would go in that way um we don't find yeah let me just find that and i can open it up and share my screen that'd be great while i'm waiting i want to just say that uh ken weila that's a great haircut could you send that to all of us uh mr rebel please yep thanks it's also posted on the website i'll get it from there thanks just one moment So far, so good.
We see you both.
Excellent.
Do you want me to start, Mr.
Chairman?
Go ahead.
Unless you think you need the PowerPoint, you can go ahead.
I can start a little bit.
One of the things we want to cover is the Medicaid population.
And I just want to remind folks, I know there's a lot of folks there that have been there longer than I have.
But I just want anybody who doesn't remember that when the state of New Hampshire originally went out for managed care, the actuaries had said that the state of New Hampshire was doing such a great job that there really wasn't any money to be saved.
So part of the cost equation that we see now is because we moved from using our own people who were doing a great job into a place where people needed to actually make money.
And even though we thought that we were going to get savings, we didn't.
So my first page starts with the Medicaid care management.
They're on the page two.
I'm sorry, page two?
Yeah.
When we look at that, the department implemented the Medicaid care management through a contract which had told us that there was anticipated savings of about 30 million dollars.
As you can see from the chart, the costs have done nothing but gone up.
And part of the reason is that only three percent of the actual population is being served by this.
So we're spending an awful lot of money for a small amount of people, and the savings just aren't there.
And again, I want to point out that the difference between a company that needs to make money and the people we had before is huge.
And that's one of the biggest problems with what we see in this paper.
You'll see now between 2014 and now, we're up to over a billion dollars for this particular portion of the system.
Now, if we can go to page three, I just want to point out the difference between case management and care management.
Case management is a medical service.
It's defined by CMS through federal regs, and it's delivered to a recipient directly.
Case management consists of the services which help recipients gain access to needed medical, social, educational, and other services.
Case management can be targeted specifically to define groups of enrollees such as waiver populations or defined groups of individuals such as elderly and adult disabled.
Case management must be provided by individuals who are free from a conflict of interest, such as a fiduciary responsibility to an employer.
Case management services include assessment of an eligible recipient, development of a specific care plan, referral to services, and monitoring and follow-up activities, case management may not be provided by the insurance company.
Now, care management is not case management.
It's actually the insurance company.
When care management is provided by the insurers, such as the NMCO, it's considered to be an administrative or financial function of the insurance company, according to CMS and federal regulations.
Thank you.
such as the NMCO, it's considered to be an administrative or financial function of the insurance company, according to CMS and federal regulations.
Care management is not a recognized medical service delivered to a recipient.
Although the function may be performed by medical personnel, these individuals are not employed to deliver a medical service to a consumer, and they're not required to be free from conflict of interest.
Primary goal of care management is to authorize and manage consumption of services to benefit the bottom line of an insurer which may or may not result in a positive outcome for the recipient.
And here's my ad for the day.
New Hampshire has a disparity rate issue with case management rates which is prohibited.
It's been stated in the budget before you is intended to fix this issue.
Please consider putting a note in the budget which specifies the rate to be paid case management.
If we go to the next slide please.
These are three contracts or examples of contracts with no deliverables.
In 2012, New Hampshire was the first state in the country to receive new Medicaid grant dollars under the Balancing Incentive Program.
Some of you may remember we call it BIP.
And we were awarded $26.5 million over three years, provided by the Affordable Care Act to keep people out of institutions and living productive lives in their communities.
Proportion of these funds were used to contract with the University of Maine, Muskegee School of Public Service, and in November 26, 2013, work began on developing a conflict-free case management model for New Hampshire.
The resulting report was not released by New Hampshire DHHS because they did not like the report's solution.
Three of New Hampshire's 1950 C waivers.
Senator Clegg, just if you would, would you be careful not to imply motivations of DHHS?
It's a big department with a lot of people.
So I understand that your perception is that they didn't like the results, so they buried it.
But I just would ask you to be a little careful there, sir.
OK.
So we're under a corrective action plan for failing to mitigate the conflict of interest violations of the case management provided.
Then we move to Navigant guide house contract, which was first approved by the GNC on May 17, 2017, and was item 12 being subsequently amended by GNC on April of 2019 as item 14.
The report has yet to be released.
The contract amount was $754,300.
The contractor met with over 100 stakeholders to solicit input to develop a plan for the CFI waiver.
The report was due by the contract end date of June 30, 2020.
On August 3, 2020, in regard to questions about the report, the department staff reported, we are validating the stakeholder input through our data-driven work.
The Alvarez and Masal contract, this is a sole source contract that went through GMC on September 2020.
As an information item only, the contract amount is for $1.5 million, all federal CARES Act funds.
The contract's purpose is stated as, the purpose of this agreement is for the contractor to conduct strategic assessment of the department's operations to quantify the financial impact the COVID-19 pandemic has had on the department's expenditures and revenues and general operations.
The contract will identify programmatic quality improvements to increase the efficiency of department operations, reduce cost savings, and improve the delivery of services during and after the COVID-19 pandemic.
The contract's specific reliance on department leadership to develop a plan to identify and discuss strategic priorities, legislative and funding challenges presented by the COVID-19 pandemic.
Also long-term goals with department leadership without any stakeholder input.
If the stakeholder input had been solicited, this would yet be one more report they did not find the solutions in.
We go to the next one, MMIS.
Good slide number, isn't it?
Uh, no, we got it.
This is the, one of the other problems that we've had over the years, it's the MMIS, Medicaid Management Information System.
Believe it or not, I was actually in the legislature when we started this one.
The new MMIS system contract was originally led in in December of 2005 to affiliated computer services, which was then brought up by Xerox in 2010.
The total contract cost, total of the initial contract was for $60 million.
$26 million was for the design phase.
$34 million was for a full five-year operational phase.
The design phase was supposed to be completed by the end of 2007 and operations were scheduled to begin on January 1, 2008.
By June of 2014, shortly after the new system went live, the cost skyrocketed over $117 million.
The union later reported that the MS design had been modified at least five times with the executive council repeatedly voting to extend the contract after Xerox missed eight deadlines over a six-year period.
According to the paper, the reason for the design changes and delays were caused by both state and federal regulations, system requirements, as well as contractive information problems.
New Hampshire continued to pay EDS, which is now HP, the legacy vendor and losing vendor to keep the existing system operation for those nine years at a cost of over $8 million a year.
We paid almost as much to maintain the system as we did for the new one.
Now, I'm going to say from personal experience back then, the problem with that is the legislature didn't keep control what they allowed was they allowed the agency to continuously make changes add different parts and then as one person said instead of starting with something off the shelf we thought we had to start with something that was brand new and when you get 15 people deciding what goes into it you've got soup that doesn't taste very good and and I would say that was one of the biggest boondoggles because even now while this was supposed to replace all of the systems it hasn't and it really doesn't work that well.
Next slide, please.
The New Hampshire state plan amendments.
New Hampshire has several of these for case management which have been approved by CMS.
The department is not in compliance with the SBA.
It is filed for the waivers which are under corrective action.
Not complying with the state plan amendments puts New Hampshire at great financial risk that the federal government will come in and ask for monetary recoupment.
Next slide, please.
We've also started with the money follows the person nursing home transition grant.
That started off as a robust program contracted to the New Hampshire Healthcare Association and New Hampshire Independent Case Management Association, which was very successful by any measure.
New Hampshire DHHS made a decision to bring the program back into the department and the program floundered.
New Hampshire missed the September 2020 opportunity when the Senators for Medicare and Medicaid Services offered 33 states up to $165 million in supplemental funding to states currently operating Money Follows the Person.
There will be awards for 2021 and we strongly suggest that this committee take a look at how we might be able to receive some of that money.
Next slide please.
For over 20 years, New Hampshire stated the goal to rebalance its long-term services and support system.
That's for our elderly and adult populations and move from a heavily institutional-based model to a less costly model with more community-based care options.
New Hampshire DHHS has expended millions of federal dollars in SIM, VEP, MFP, et cetera, to accomplish the stated goal.
There is no measure by which you could establish this goal has been achieved.
When we look at the demographic data on COVID-19 deaths, over 70% of the deaths were residents of New Hampshire nursing homes.
And we have learned nothing else from the experience of the pandemic.
It has brought to light our failures in LTSS and it's time we acknowledge them.
Once again, for the next biennium, the institutional arm of the system will be funded at far greater than the community alternative.
If the immediate needs of the community-based care system are not addressed, we will lose the option of community-based care.
New Hampshire has state plan amendments for the 1915 C waiver case management, which has been approved by CMS.
The department is not in compliance with the SBA for the waivers which we are under corrective action.
Next slide for duplication.
Thank you.
We have an example of what we consider to be duplication and it's in the the 2021 House Bill 2, 38 Managed Care Contract deliverables.
The appropriation is for the Department of Health and Human Services expanded and continued admissions, discharge, transfer event notifications.
There is hereby appropriated the Department of Health and Human Services the sum of 200,000 for the biennium ending June 30, 2023, to support expanded and continued admission, discharge, transfer events, notification capabilities that accelerate notifications of a patient's admission, discharge, and or transfer to other health providers involved in a patient's care.
The governor is authorized to draw a warrant to send some out of the money in the treasury not otherwise appropriate.
Then on 2.1, 1-2-2.1, transitional case management means the responsibility of the MCO to manage transitions of care for all members moving from one clinical setting to another to prevent unplanned or unnecessary readmissions.
ED visits or adverse health outcomes, the MOO shall maintain and operate formalized hospital and or institutional discharge planning program that includes effective post-discharge transitional care management, including appropriate discharge planning for short-term and long-term hospital and institutional states.
Transitional health care means care that is available from a primary or specialty provider for clinical assessment and care, planning within two weeks, business days of discharge for the inpatient, or institutional care for the physical and mental health disorders or discharge from a substance use disorder treatment.
What we're saying here is, do we really need $200,000 to have two people talk to each other?
They both seem to be doing the same thing.
So I question whether or not it really costs us $200,000.
Maybe they can just share a piece of paper.
My last slide is about real people.
It's my personal opinion that DHHS has lost sight of its mission and what it means to address the needs of real people with real issues and to give them the tools they need to continue to live in the real world.
Institutionalization serves neither the state nor the people we call our fellow citizens.
We spend millions of dollars looking for solutions that are not accepted when offered.
It's time we hit the pause button, implement the solutions we have paid for, and stop spending money because we don't like the solutions offered, and dedicate those funds to the Medicaid recipients.
Last session you increased the DHHS budget by 24%.
The results so far have not resulted in any improvement.
It's my personal belief that we should hold on to any new spending ideas until we see the results of the 24% increase of the last session's ideas.
No corporation would continue to spend money without causative results.
And I say that after many years of being involved, that it's time that we either found out what works and what doesn't work.
And one of the biggest problems I see in government is when we have something that works, somebody decides to spend as much money or more on a new idea to see if there's something better.
My idea is that we go back to what works and we keep it.
Imagine living with the same program for eight years while we spend $117 million to replace it.
It's not as good as the old system.
So why did we even need to replace it to begin with?
don't know so my suggestion is on a personal level that your committee look at leaving the budget the way it is and asking HHS to actually show how services were improved for the people that you serve and not just how the bottom line improves thank Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, for the opportunity.
You can ask any questions if you have any.
First, I want to thank you for putting this together and coming in and spending time with us.
You did that at my request because I was interested in a 10-year overview, and I thank you for volunteering your time in the way that you have.
So are there any questions for Senator Clegg or Carolyn Virtue?
I see one from Representative Weiler.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I just want to say hello to my two old friends.
And thank you for that information.
We never hear it from HHS.
So I appreciate that other view.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
That's wonderful to see you today.
If I may, I do miss not sitting in those plastic chairs for hours on end.
Well, we have different chairs now.
We get to pick our own at our own house, so it's a little different.
All right.
Well, thank you.
Just to take note of the time, we invested almost 20 minutes there, which is a little bit more than I anticipated.
What I'm going to do at this point is to have Representative Walner.
And I don't know if we talked about this very thoroughly, but I know that you've invited Gina Balkus, Maura O'Neill, Jackie Kroll.
So maybe we can give you 30 to 40 minutes to see if you can get those three through.
If you can't, don't sweat it, okay?
Okay, I actually, I think that we actually had told the folks 20 minutes.
I thought that was what our, what it was.
You are absolutely right.
No, no.
I don't think we can do it.
I have to correct myself because you're right and I'm wrong.
My memory stored 10 minutes for some reason and in fact and in fact it's 20 so you're right so you have an hour okay so um i think sharon um or kathy invited gina balkas and so i would let them take introduce her um i invited her kevin is?
Yep, I'm bringing her in now.
She's there but she's muted.
Yes, good afternoon.
Thank you so much.
I'll let you introduce yourself.
Go ahead.
Thank you so much.
My sound clicked off there for a minute when Kevin connected me.
Thank you so much for inviting me, Representative Rogers.
My name is Gina Balkus, and I am the CEO of the Home Care Hospice and Palliative Care Alliance and its advocacy affiliate, the Granite State Home Health and Hospice Association.
And we represent about 43 home care agencies across the state.
And Representative Rogers invited me today to speak about choices for independence.
And I was planning on 20 minutes.
I have 10 slides.
I think I can get through it in less than that, but let's see how it goes.
So I'm gonna try to share my screen now.
You do have 20 minutes.
I apologize for being confused earlier.
And can everybody see this?
No.
Can you see my screen?
Not, well we can see you but we can't see uh we can't see the present Okay.
Let me go back in here.
I'll share.
Okay.
And let me, can you see that?
Yes.
Great.
Thank you.
Okay.
So, as I mentioned, I will, we've got a lot to cover, so I will get through this.
So yesterday you had a presentation from the Department of Health and Human Services, and Deb Sheets spoke about the Choices for Independence program, and I'm going to just review it really quickly.
So CFI is a waiver service under Medicaid.
It's really intended for elderly and adult citizens.
Adults can be anywhere from 21 and up who need nursing home level of care.
And so those folks go through a financial eligibility.
So it's based, it's primarily for low income individuals and a clinical eligibility where they're assessed by a department nurse.
And then they're determined to be eligible for services by BES staff.
But I think the important thing to remember here is that these people are determined to need a nursing home level of care.
So they're very vulnerable and they need a lot of support.
But the beauty of the Choices for Independence program is it allows people to live at home with supportive services.
And let's face it, most people would prefer to be at home rather than in a group setting or a nursing home.
But the other beauty of CFI, when it's working well, is that it's a really good investment for the state.
The average annual cost is less than $20,000 per year per individual compared to over $50,000 for nursing home care.
So, Mr.
Chairman, you asked that when we speak, we talk about the lines that we're addressing.
And yesterday, I believe that Karen Rounds showed you this page.
This is page 551 in House Bill 1.
And specifically, CFI is in three lines.
So line 505 is mid-level care.
That's residential care facilities, meaning not nursing homes, but residences for seniors assisted living.
506 is home support waiver services.
And you'll notice that this line has about $56 million in it.
I call this the kitchen sink line.
There's a lot in this.
There's personal care services.
There is meals on wheels.
The case managers get paid from this line.
Things like pill planners, equipment that people might need at home is in class 506.
And then class 529 home health waiver services are some specific home health services.
So I'm going to, and I'm here today to talk specifically about the home health services that are delivered in these two lines.
Thank you.
here today to talk specifically about the home health services that are delivered in these two lines.
So let's talk about what those services are.
For CFI clients, they can receive nursing visits.
Keep in mind that if they were in a nursing home, they would be a nurse overseeing their care 24 hours a day.
So nurses visit the client as determined based on their needs.
It might be once a week, twice a week, once a month.
And there are clinical assessments done to check in to see how the client is doing.
They put together care plans.
They address wound care and catheter care.
A lot of what they do is help people with their medications.
So it comes from filling the pill planners.
When the doctor changes the medication, it's a nurse that goes to the home to change out the pill planner.
And be sure that clients are getting the medications they need.
There's also a lot of patient and family education.
This is what nurses do.
They help people understand their illnesses.
They help them understand how they can care for themselves, what they need to do, for instance, to deal with their diabetes in terms of eating well, what they need to be careful of if they have congestive heart failure so that they're not eating too much salty food.
So this is what really nurses do.
And then they supervise home health aides.
And this is in class 529.
The next category is home health aid services.
And there's a lot of correlation between what home health aides do and what personal care providers do.
But home health aides are licensed nursing assistants.
They're licensed by the Board of Nursing.
They've completed 100 hours of training and they work under the supervision of a nurse and they observe and they report medical conditions.
They assist with bathing, toileting, dental care.
They help with the transfers in and out of bed, dressing, walking, feeding.
They can be delegated to actually administer medications.
So they're a higher level of service than personal care services.
These are also in class 529.
Personal care services is in class 506.
And these are unlicensed personnel.
They have about 16 hours of training, six of which is specifically state mandated dementia care training.
And I might add that the LNAs also have to go through those six hours of mandated dementia care training.
And personal care providers do bathing, toileting, dental care.
Once again, they assist with these activities of daily living.
They remind people to take their medications, and they might do transportation to, say, grocery, pharmacy, and other services.
So what's the difference here?
Really, what you're talking about here is you might send an L&A to a CFI client who has some serious medical conditions, whereas somebody here might get personal care services for somebody who may not have medical conditions, but is just simply frail and needs some help, you know, around the house, getting up and out of bed, that sort of thing.
And some clients get both.
You know, you might have a home health aide who goes in twice a week, but then you have a personal care provider who goes in five days a week.
And then we have homemaker services.
And this is also in class 526.
And this is light housekeeping, grocery shopping, changing the sheets, doing the laundry, preparing meals for the week.
So these are the type of services that help people remain independent and stay at home and out of nursing homes.
So let's talk about some of the challenges that CFI has.
And I think this is something that Deb Sheets addressed yesterday.
First of all, you have a growing caseload and that's a function of New Hampshire's demographics.
We are an aging state.
We have one of the highest levels of people over age 65 in the country.
And so as you can see, between 2015 and 2020, the caseload of people who relying on CFI services has really grown.
But then there's another real more serious challenge with increasing caseload, and that's gaps of care.
And when I say gaps of care, I mean undelivered services.
So the alliance...
I just want to make sure I'm understanding these percentages.
Are these services that are okay?
In this case, in skilled nursing visits, are we providing 68% of the work or only 32%?
We're providing 68% of the work and 32% of the authorized services are undelivered.
So let me just explain the process a little bit.
When somebody is determined to be eligible for the program, and that eligibility can take about 60 days is what Deb told you yesterday, then they are assigned an independent case manager, very much like Granite State case management that from our previous speakers.
That case manager, the department authorizes a range of services and says to the case manager, these are the service that the client is authorized for.
You go make it happen.
And then somebody like Carolyn Virtue will then reach out to Meals on Wheels, to a home health agency, to DME providers, to others to get them the services that they need.
So what I'm showing you here is that between 2017 and 2020, the department authorized a set of services and in the the case of skilled nursing, 32% of the authorized services were not delivered.
That's the average over the four years.
For home health aid, when I say short visits, it means visits under two hours.
45% of those visits that were authorized were not delivered.
For home health aid long visits, these are visits that are over two hours, 31% of the visits were not delivered.
In personal care, which is the largest service that is provided from home health agencies, 25% of the services were not delivered.
Homemaker services, 45% not delivered.
So let's talk about what that really means.
If somebody has diabetes or congestive heart failure and they need a nurse, you know, to be coming in to check on them, it means that, you know, some of their visits that they're authorized to get, they are not receiving.
In the case of personal care and home health aides, sometimes this is helping people get out of bed in the morning, helping them get out of bed and get dressed.
So if they're authorized for seven days a week to have somebody help them get undressed, and they can only receive services for five days a week, what happens on those other two days?
If there is...
come help them get undressed and they can only receive services for five days a week, what happens on those other two days?
If they're incontinent, it means they may not get a bath or a shower.
It means that their sheets that may need to be changed on a daily basis because of their incontinence don't get changed half the time.
And, you know, as somebody who cared for my aging parents before they died, I know how important it is for elderly people or people who have disabilities to get these services every day for the services if that's what they need.
Missing a day has consequences.
And I think that a really good example for, say, somebody who might be elderly and incontinent is that if they're not bathed regularly, if their garments not changed regularly, then they develop skin sores.
If they don't get out of bed every day, or if they sit in their chair all day, if they don't get up and moving, they get pressure ulcers.
And those pressure ulcers, if they're not seen on a regular basis by their nurse or their home health aid, can result in major infections that require hospitalizations.
I mean, pressure ulcers are a major risk factor for elderly people.
And people can be in the hospital for weeks if they get a severe infection.
The same thing with falls.
If they can't get help getting out of bed and somebody falls, it can result in injuries that end up in hospitalization and rehab stays.
So there are real consequences to these gaps in care.
And I just want the committee to understand that these gaps in care are really problematic.
And so the other growing challenge really is that the payments to providers are just not based on economic realities.
And that's part of what's contributing to the gaps in care.
So let's talk a little bit about provider payments.
So when the department pays a home care agency, they pay them based on the time that the home health aide or the personal care provider or the nurse is in the home.
So if the provider, if the individual is authorized for say a two-hour home health aide visit, then the payment rate that is paid to them is the rate for a two-hour visit.
But that visit isn't all that the agency does.
That rate has to cover all these other expenses from not just the wages for the caregiver, but the wages for the supervisor.
And home care agencies also have care managers that help, that work with the independent case managers.
It's managers.
It's not a duplication of services.
I mean, the home care agency, before they even assign a personal caregiver, will go interview the person, that individual, to be sure to find out what they're like, what their parent personality is like, what kind of person from the agency staff is going to be the right fit for that person.
And then you have mileage and travel time.
And let's keep in mind, New Hampshire is a rural state.
There's a lot of driving on back roads and up mountains and dirt roads to get to the clients that rely on these services.
There's workers comp, payroll taxes, benefits, you know, the agency's professional liability insurance.
There's training, including, you know, the recently mandated six hours of dementia training a year and four hours in continuing.
It's a good thing, but there's a cost to it.
And agencies are obligated by the legislature to pay their staff while they're going through that training.
There's criminal background tests and TB tests, and now COVID tests that need to be done on a regular basis.
And then there's the administrative issues of scheduling and case management, overtime and billing.
So I just want you to keep in mind, as I review the rates, it's not just about the time that the client is getting one-on-one care.
It's about all the background information services that are provided behind the scenes.
And I wouldn't call that, you know, overhead.
This is direct expense related to the program.
So let's talk about the rates.
And I know you're the finance committee, and I hate to bore you with lots of data, but I think you're the folks that dig into this, so I want you to understand this.
So right now, in 2021, the rate for a nursing visit, regardless of whether it's 30 minutes or two hours, is $100.63.
And that's based, that includes the 3.1% rate increase that went into effect on January 1 of 2021, and is still in effect in the governor's proposed budget.
Okay, there is no rate increase built in to the governor's budget, it just maintains the existing rate.
But I Thank you.
budget.
Okay, there is no rate increase built in to the governor's budget, it just maintains the existing rate.
But what I've tried to do here is compare the CFI rates to the governor's proposed rates to the Title 20 and 3B program, which is another BES program that is mostly federally funded.
And this is for people who are under age 60, who are not on Medicaid, but who are at risk.
And it's like I said, it's mostly federally funded.
This program doesn't cover nursing visits.
So that's why there's an NA.
And then I also looked at what the national data is for private rates in the general community.
And so I used the Genworth cost of care survey, which is a major long-term care provider, insurance provider.
And these are the median rates for 2020.
And so median, which means some are paying more, that service did not look at nursing visits.
And then I looked at Medicare cost reports.
So the most recent cost report data available is, and this is agencies that provide care to Medicare beneficiaries have to report all their costs to the federal government and their costs include all the costs that are allocated to delivering care.
In the New Hampshire average for cost of care for a nursing visit is $170 a visit.
And that was in 2018, which is the most recent data available.
So this gives you a sense of where the state compares to the cost of care.
For home health aid visits, now the state pays out in CFI, pays it two ways.
If the visit is less than two hours, there's a one flat fee of $33.03.
If it's paid, if it's over two hours, then it's paid in 15-minute increments of $6.41 per per 15 minute, which gets you to an hourly rate of $26.64 per hour.
So right now, CFI is paying $33.
The governor's proposed budget doesn't change that.
There is no comparable data available for these programs, but the Medicare rate for a visit, a home health aid visit, is $60 for a visit.
Under the unit rates, 2664.
And I think this is a typo.
This should be also, it's unchanged.
It should be 2664.64.
So I will correct that in the PDF that I've sent to Kevin.
That's a typo.
When I've looked at New Hampshire title 20 and three B rates, the state of New Hampshire is paying $32 an hour.
They pay in 30 minute increments of $16 perhaps an hour.
So you can see there's a big discrepancy for what I would consider a lower level of care.
These are people that are not eligible for nursing home care, people who are in to the Title 20 programs, but they're considered at risk, whereas the people who are in CFI are eligible for nursing home care, and yet the rate is $6 an hour less, $26.64.
And then let's talk about personal care.
So currently, under the 2021 CFI rates, the state is paying $4.89 per 15-minute unit, comes out to $19.56 an hour.
You heard Deb Sheets from the department say yesterday that in the governor's budget, there is a budgeted rate increase to $5.62 per unit, which would get you to $22.48 an hour.
okay um this is still less than what I would say within $32 an hour for home health aids.
Although, you know, once again, this is, these people are the, the, the, the aids, the caregiver has more, a little bit more experience, but then let's look at the private marketplace.
The private market, the immediate rate in New Hampshire is $29.50.
So if you're an agency that, well, and so let's just go through Homemaker now.
Homemaker currently pays $5.09 for CFI, which ironically is higher than the personal care rate above.
So what I tell people is that the current rates, I've lost my mouse here to show you what I'm referring to, the current rates, the people who wash the laundry, the rate to pay for people who wash the laundry is higher than the CFI rate for the people who bathe the individuals.
So I'm pleased that the department is raising these rates and fixing this discrepancy.
So Deb Sheets told you yesterday that home acre rates are going up to $5.40 per unit.
So the rate increase that's in the governor's budget is a step in the right direction.
But once again, under the Title 3B program, the state pays $24 an hour for homemaker services, and the private market pays $28.50.
So if you're an agency that provides services to Title 20 and 3B clients, CFI clients, and private pay clients, and you only have so many caregivers to provide care, which ones would you, if you have to choose which clients you're going to serve, well, who's it going to be?
It will likely be the private pay in the title programs and the CFI clients will likely go unserved.
And that's why you're starting to see, well, you're not just starting, you've been seeing gaps in care for years.
But I think it's really reaching a major crisis.
I'm going to just cover this quickly, but Jeb alluded to workforce shortages.
This is the reality of the climate we are in.
The Home Care Alliance had Helms and Company do a vacancy rate and turnover rate survey in February.
So for the week of 1231, this is a snapshot in time, and it can change weekly.
There was a 23% vacancy rate for registered nurses and about 30 to 33% vacancy rate for licensed practical nurses, many of which do the skilled nursing visits for CFI clients, home health aid, personal care, and homemakers.
The staff turnover rate, which is an annual average based on their monthly payrolls, their monthly turnovers of people who are exiting the agencies.
Look at these turnover rates.
Personal care providers turning over 41% turnover rate.
Licensed practical nurses a 51% turnover rate.
This is the reality that agencies are dealing with.
And so when we have challenges where the rates are not adequate to pay adequate wages, and when you're in a competitive marketplace, and you have other employers like Walmart, Target, Hobby Lobby, that provide, pay $15 an hour, Costco's going up to $16 an hour for a job that's not as hard.
I mean, the work that personal care providers and home health aides do is hard work.
It's emotional work.
It's physically challenging to lift people in and out of bed.
These workforce challenges are real.
And unfortunately, the rates have not been adjusted over the years to reflect what's going on in the marketplace.
So here are some, I've got two slides to talk about the public policy issues.
Let's just start.
CFI is a great program.
It really helps people remain in their homes, and it's less than the cost of nursing home care, and it's where people want to be.
You know, New Hampshire people are, they're sturdy Yankees.
They don't want to depend on people, other people for care.
They want to be independent and CFI lets them be independent with some help.
But I would say that based on what I've told you about the gaps in care, that New Hampshire is really failing in its commitment to support individuals.
And I don't necessarily, I don't know, I can't blame the department for that.
I can't, you know, there's a lot of, there's a lot of going on, you know, the workforce shortage, a pandemic, especially hard in the pandemic.
I didn't even show you the data for the gaps in care based on the pandemic.
It's much, much worse in 2021.
But, you know, I would say that over the years, the legislature has a role to play in this problem.
Advocates have been asking for years for CFI rate increases.
I mean, when you look at the Genworth cost of care, realistically, CFI care costs increased by about 4% a year.
And New Hampshire has sometimes gone 10 or 12 years without a rate increase.
So while we got a rate increase on January 1, 3.1% on January 2021, 3.1% on January 2020, the last rate increase was in 2015.
So it had been 10 years prior to that where there were no increases.
So a lot of this is based on just public policy decisions that have been made.
But keep in mind that these low rates are crippling providers, and that's why you're seeing gaps in care.
I think that how else is it failing?
I mean, we are creating dangerous conditions for individuals.
Somebody like this gentleman, if he doesn't have help getting out of bed in the morning, if he hasn't have help getting dressed, he has a fall risk.
A broken hip means surgery.
It means time in the hospital.
it means months in a skilled nursing rehab facility, and maybe that person never goes back home.
They stay in a nursing facility.
um and there's really and i think the other thing that's important is there are wait lists for people to get services um there are wait lists and i think the department can't say they're a wait list because There are wait lists for people to get services.
There are wait lists, and I think the department can't say there are wait lists because they're not allowed to have wait lists, but the people have been determined to be eligible for care and they've been assigned to a case manager, but the case manager can't find agencies to fill the hours and provide the services that these folks need.
And I think there's just an incredible risk of hospitalization in nursing home.
And just the reality is that we have heard stories of people who've died while waiting for services.
And I think if you asked case managers, you would hear these stories.
And then the reality is this, home care providers are either limiting the number of CFI clients they can accept because they're losing tens of thousands of dollars a year or more, six figures a year providing this service, or they're quietly just ceasing participation in the program.
They're saying we can't take any more, we'll serve the clients we have, or we're going to transfer them to another provider.
And that's the reality of what's going on.
And then lastly, so what can you do from finance committee?
I think it's important for you to know that between 2017 and 2020, I requested data from the department and it showed me that just in CFI home health services alone, that between 11 million to $15 million a year were unspent in the budget.
And what I'm saying is, what I mean by that is the department authorized services and based on unit of services, the amount of services that they authorized had a specific dollar amount.
And when you look at how many claims were really paid out for services delivered, that each year between 11 and 15 million dollars was unspent.
So that money lapses to the general fund.
I don't believe that it lapses in the middle of the biennium, but it lapses at the end of the biennium.
So we are using budgeted funds to fill the laps.
And instead, the department could be using those to increase the rates to market level in order to stabilize the delivery of services.
So I'm not here asking you for more money.
I'm saying the department should not be leaving money on the table and budget and lapsing it to the general fund.
It should be used, put into rate increases.
And I realize there's a catch-22.
you could say, well, if we increase the rates and more services that are delivered, then we'll spend overspend the line.
I don't think you're going to get to 100% of authorized services anytime soon, even with increasing the rates.
But maybe you could get to 85 or 95% of services being delivered.
That would be a much safer situation for people who depend on CFI.
The legislature should really direct the department to further increase the home health rates within the proposed appropriation.
And I think, I know that Deb mentioned in the home health realm that it would be for personal care providers and homemakers.
I think you really need to increase home health aid rates as well.
These are the services that are most frequently used, and this is where there are major gaps in care.
And so I would really urge you to look at that.
And I think the rates should be as high as the Title 20 and 3B rates and even closer to the private market rates.
The other thing that I would recommend is that the state consider adopting a footnote similar to the nursing home footnote that's currently in the budget.
And if you'd like, I would direct you back to page 551.
There is a footnote for nursing homes that says that at the end of the fiscal year, that any money that is left in the line is paid out to providers as a one-time rate enhancement.
And I think that that would get to the $11 million to $15 million dollars that's not being spent a year.
I think this is something you should really consider.
And then lastly, you should know that in the federal stimulus bill that was passed by the House, by Congress and passed by the Senate, and now is going back to the House for consideration and eventually going to President Biden's desk.
It includes a 10% federal match increase for home and community-based services for April 1st through, I have another typo there, through March 31st of 2022.
So for a year, there will be more federal dollars coming into the state for these services and other services like Medicaid, state plan, home health services.
And these funds cannot supplant existing funds.
They have to be used to strengthen programs.
So there should be more money in the budget to increase rates.
So those are some of the things that I hope that you will discuss in your committee.
And this is my contact information.
I'm happy to take any questions that you have.
Also, Henry Veyu from She and Finney Capital Group is our lobbyist.
And I know many of you you know Henry and you can reach out to him.
And lastly, you know, these keep in mind, I know that you're the committee that deals with numbers, but just remember there are real people out there living in homes, relying on services, and depending on the state for care.
And I think we can't ever lose sight that every one of these people has a story and their story is an important story and the services they receive are important.
So with that, I'm going to stop sharing and take any questions.
And I don't know how I did on time.
Sorry.
So, well, this is Mary Jane.
I don't know if representative Edwards wants me to go and you went a little over your time.
So I don't know if there are questions or not.
I don't hear any so I think maybe representative Edwards, would you like us to move on now?
Sure.
Thank you so much for the opportunity to speak.
Thank you for the really great presentation.
Thank you, Gina.
I just want to say it was a very powerful presentation, very well delivered.
I appreciated your use of common language to just make clear points.
Thank you.
Do you want me to go on with the next one?
Please.
Okay.
I think next maybe we'll have Jackie Cowell.
She's from Early Learning New Hampshire and she's going to speak a little bit about the child care budget.
And I can tell you it can be found in your budget book.
I think she's going to speak about she's going to speak about the child care budget, which is on page 950 of your budget book.
And it's employment related child childcare and protective and preventive childcare.
And so Jackie Cowell.
I'll keep time.
Okay.
I think Jackie's presentation might be a little shorter than Gina's.
Oh, I think maybe I brought in the wrong person.
Hold on.
It's C-O-W-E-L-L.
I think.
Okay, she's coming in now.
Okay.
How do you do?
Hi, Jackie.
Hi.
Good afternoon, committee members of Division three.
I'm very excited to be here talking with you about the child care budget.
There are two lines that I'd like to talk with you about.
Kevin, I don't have a presentation, so we'll just have a conversation.
but if you don't mind if you wanted me to share my screen and point to the budget but it is as Mary Jane indicated it's it's 950.
And the two lines, it's under account 2977 Child Development Program.
And the two lines that I'm going to be talking about are class 536, towards the bottom of the page, employment-related child care, and 564, protective and preventive child care.
So I just wanted to tell you about what those programs are designed to do and to talk about what needs to, what we believe needs to happen in those lines.
and so employment-related child care, I'll start with class 536, again towards the bottom of the page.
As you might have seen in the budget, during this biennium, there are $30 million in the first year and $34 million in the second year.
And the governor is proposing, as the department also proposed, cutting that down to 26 million in the first year of the next biennium and actually a little bit less in the second year of the biennium.
That's a significant cut.
And here's what this program does.
This is employment-related child care.
These are families, parents that are working who have young children.
So children anywhere from a baby all the way through age 12 might be going to an after-school program who are income eligible to receive state child care assistance.
The purpose of this program is to give them enough assistance so they can keep working and then lift themselves out of state assistance.
And I used to run a child care program and others, Mary Jane used to others.
We've seen story after story of families who use this one bit of state assistance to get ahead and to get off of state assistance completely.
What we do find is when and if there is a wait list and they cannot get these subsidies, these scholarships, that they often become eligible for higher levels of state assistance.
And so this is a really terrific measure to make sure that they have what they need to keep working and to keep getting ahead.
And so we at Early Learning New Hampshire, we're a statewide nonprofit.
We're quite concerned with this potential cut and the potential need for a wait list if these funds run out.
We're worried these are not sufficient funds.
Historically, over time, there have been fluctuations in the number of folks who come, who are eligible, who use these services.
It can be as low as 3,000 and some, and then 5,000 and 6,000 during the recession in 2008 and 2009.
It was over 8,000, over 8,000 children whose families were income eligible using working families, using this child care assistance.
It's a bit unpredictable.
It's extremely unpredictable right now, we maintain, because of the pandemic.
It's highly likely, we know that there are a lot of folks who are obviously on unemployment right now, who therefore will be looking for job search when they can go back.
They'll be eligible for the state child care assistance.
So again, it could be more families.
There are some folks who are now not working full time.
It's so unpredictable.
We urge you to look at what mechanisms could be in place to have enough money to make sure that we don't start a wait list.
And so that's what I urge you to do.
I can't sit here and say, I know there's going to be these many children next year.
It's really hard to predict.
So I know that if you all can think of a footnote, if you all can think of a mechanism, whatever that is, to think of using some of the funds as a set aside to ensure that if it looks like there's a wait list, to make sure that the funds are there.
Because without those funds, it is highly likely they'll be eligible for higher levels of state assistance.
Many of these families that are in this income category, they don't have the choice to telework.
You know, they are certified nurse's assistants.
They are working at Wendy's, they are working at grocery stores, et cetera.
They have to be on the job.
So therefore having the childcare is critical for them to keep working.
So again, we urge you to look at that.
You may have heard that women have been the ones that have the highest job losses during the pandemic, very much more significant.
And so again, folks with young children, we really urge you to look at this line item.
The other thing I'd ask you to look at is the line of the class 564.
So that's protective and preventive child care.
So right below line 536 employment related child care that we ask you to please think of a way to have sufficient money because the last thing we need in New Hampshire is a wait list for folks who are working to be able to have the child care they need.
But the protective and preventive is there for a bit of a different reason.
As you see in the lines, it's $2 million a year.
The department had asked for an extra $2 million a year because they have actually seen more and more children eligible for this.
There are two reasons folks use the service.
One is a family might be deemed at risk of abuse and neglect.
So they receive child care services to support the family.
There also may be cases of child abuse and neglect.
That's the protective.
And again, those foster families and others, our relatives are using the child care as well.
So my really quick request is for you to have a discussion about what it would take to make sure we don't have a wait list in employment related child care..
We are quite concerned the $26 million is not sufficient for what will be needed over the biennium, and to ask to put an extra, as the department asked, $2 million a year in the protective and preventive child care line to make sure that those children are served as well.
And that's my presentation.
And I urge you to look at those slides and have that discussion.
And I'd love to answer any questions you might have.
Thank you, Jackie.
Are there questions?
I can't do the hands up.
So are there quick?
I just want to know if you're the more interesting cousin.
Simon.
No, unfortunately, no.
Thank you, though.
So thank you so much.
I appreciate your listening and I thank you.
Great.
Thank you, Jackie.
You're welcome.
So I think we're probably back on time.
Thank you for getting back on track.
And now I believe Maura O'Neill coming in.
And she is the New Hampshire child advocate.
I believe we have Maura O'Neill coming in.
And I think she's going to talk about the Sununu Center.
OK, she's coming in.
Thank you, Kevin.
Good afternoon.
Can you all hear me?
Yes, we can hear you.
Great.
Mr.
Chairman and members of the committee, thank you for the invitation to speak today.
Ripple does have my slides, or do you want me to try to share the ones I have?
If you can share, I think that would be best, but if not, I can do it.
How's that?
Have you got them?
Yes.
Let's show in from the beginning.
So there we go.
Thank you.
So I was asked to come in and speak a little bit about the Sununu Youth Services Center today.
There's been some discussion about closing the facility which has become very expensive to run for the number of children that it serves.
And I do think it's sort of breathtaking to look at the size of the complex and think about today there are 13 children there.
Two of them are from the state of Maine.
So essentially we have 11 New Hampshire children there.
And so I'm happy to talk about this.
And I also want to preface this conversation with recognizing that we have to have this conversation with care.
There are 90 people who are employed in that facility.
They go to work every day and do their best job.
They work under a great deal of stress.
And probably the biggest source of stress that they experience is these kinds of public conversations about them.
So I just want to be very careful about how we can make these considerations and be respectful of that.
Largely also because when a staff are stressed out, that affects children very much and even can be dangerous for children.
So I understand that the interest of time, I'm not going to go too deeply into background, but I did want to sort of set the stage for your thinking when you're making decisions like changing services for children.
And in particular, this is essentially the idea of closing down a prison for children, which is a movement that's been happening across the country fairly extensively.
And what we've seen since 1992, when the first juvenile detention alternatives initiatives started in Florida, was that children are actually harmed a bit when they go into incarceration, and they also are not effective programs to keep communities safe.
The most highly predictive factor of a child offending a second time is being in this system to begin with.
And we've also since then learned a lot about children's brains, and I'd love to give you a whole lecture about what that means when we talk about brain development.
And I'm happy to come back and do that at some point when you have more time.
But that has really sort of driven a lot of what we've known about where we put children, how we think about the things that we do with them.
And as we examine what are the best kinds of services for them, we've seen a shift in New Hampshire itself, building out the system of care, transforming the way we use the Sununu Center, starting with HB 517 that shifted who was admitted there.
And that's how we got to this place.
And this is a national trend.
We're seeing significantly that fewer and fewer children are being arrested and brought into juvenile systems.
This is a really good indicator.
Right now, as I mentioned to you today, there are 13 children at the Sununi Youth Services Center.
There's actually about a little over 1,700 children who are adjudicated delinquent.
Most of them are served in the community.
It's a very small population that are incarcerated.
And I include the number of children who are in residential placements because in some ways, you know, courts order children to these placements as an alternative to incarceration.
And there are some of the similar concerns about kids who are in those environments as well.
Right now, there are 39 children who are delinquent, adjudicated delinquent in the state, and 13 who have been sent out of state.
Many of the kids who are out of state are girls.
Of the 11 children that are at the Sununu Center today, two are detained and nine are committed.
We use the same facility for both detention and commitment.
At least two of the children are awaiting placement options for foster care or residential programming.
There are probably more.
It's our opinion that most of the children who are there could be treated safely in the community.
There are eight children there at police who have combined history with 82 abuse and neglect referrals ranging from seven for one child to 31 for another.
So these are the crossover children that we see.
They're children who have lived through abuse and neglect and the behavior that manifests because of their treatment and their adverse childhood experiences ends up being involved with law enforcement and adjudicated and sometimes just brought over to the juvenile system in order to get them the idea that they're getting some sort of help.
There are three children also who've had child in need of services cases.
Those are children who have behavioral issues that they can't get services any other way.
There are four that have been in multiple residential programs already.
And there are six who are there because of parole violations.
So that is the recidivism that you see people coming back.
So one of the quick things I'll just say, since I can't lecture you entirely on brain development, is some of the things that we need to think about when we think about where we're putting children.
We all have become in New Hampshire really sort of expert about being responsive to trauma and understanding what happens to children when they have been traumatized or adverse childhood experiences.
But the other side of that that we need to be thinking about is how to heal children, what will make them healthy and get their development back on track.
So there are four sort of pillars of hope that Robert Zaghi and his colleagues use to describe the important things that will help children be successful.
One is that consistent caring adult, an adult who is committed to a child and the child feels they have that strong relationship.
The next is to live, play, and learn in a safe, stable environment and not to be in fear all the time.
And then the third is to feel that you belong to a community.
So it's really important when you move kids away from a community, they lose that and they don't feel valued.
You want to have that sense of belonging.
And then finally, to be given the skills to be able to manage their emotions in a healthy way, which is how they'll manage their behaviors.
So it's been very difficult to talk with folks about considering closing down a youth prison and right now in the United States because New Hampshire is so far ahead of everyone.
I mean, there really are a lot of eyes on this state for the progress that we've made.
And I know for many people, it doesn't feel that way.
But the idea of trying to resolve an issue of 11 kids who are in a facility is almost sort of adorable to many of the states around us who are dealing with hundreds of kids, and they consider themselves fully transformed and doing different ways of juvenile justice.
But when you have conversations with them, they'll tell you before you close the facility, you have to have all these things.
And all of the things they mentioned are things that we either have, or we're in the process, thanks to Senate Bill 14 from 2019.
The mobile crisis response that not just helps kids at home, but actually goes to schools and where a lot of offenses come from the school environment.
So instead of police responding, you have clinicians responding.
These expanded wraparound care coordinating services that work with families and children to help them manage issues at home so that minimizes behavioral problems.
We have an RFP out right now for multisystemic therapy, which is the most evidence-based intensive program for children to keep them out of incarcerated situations.
MST for about the average length of stay is three to four months for about, I think it's up to $15,000 roundabout per child.
And there are evidences that not only will that child not re-offend, but that child's siblings won't offend and the child's parents won't offend.
It's a really exceptional program.
We're very excited that it's coming to New Hampshire.
And the care management entities and the comprehensive assessment treatment, these are essentially they're independent bodies who are going to be looking at kids, assessing their needs and matching them to services so that they don't end up just placed randomly in residential care that's not really designed to meet their needs.
And they're going to be watching them to make sure that they're making progress.
So it's when children are placed someplace for care and it's not adequate for them that they start sliding and they end up in an assaultive situation and end up at the Sununu Center.
And there's also an RFP out for actual procured residential services that will be under contract for the first time so that we can hold providers accountable to provide services that are effective and that meet children's needs and that children move on rapidly to get back to their community.
So they have that sense of belonging and maintaining those relationships.
And there's also a whole probation transformation happening.
And there's a bill, Senate Bill 94, I think, that would that would have the law enforcement when they encounter a child who's broken the law, can refer them to the department for an assessment of their needs.
And if we discover that their needs would, if they were met, would also mitigate the risk to the community, then they never get petitions for adjudication.
They just go right to whatever service is going to help them.
So I'm mentioning these things.
I know you've heard a lot about some of them in the conversations with the department the last couple of weeks, but I'm mentioning these in the context of, this is gonna drive a more diminishing rate of children coming into the Sununu Center.
It's almost gonna empty out just sort of organically.
But we know that people believe that we still need some alternative when we have to, when we have a child that we need to keep safe from the community.
And so we propose the two models that we spent the last week really talking to experts around the country to see, you know, what are the best models.
And one is the Missouri model style secure bed or 12 to 14 bed secure home and this multidimensional treatment foster care.
I'll tell you a little bit more about these.
So the Missouri model, which has been around for a while and it's been somewhat modified as they go.
We are suggesting a 12 to 14 bed secure facility.
We don't think you're going to actually need 12 to 14 beds.
You're probably going to need five to six, but there seems to be a sense in the community that you have to be prepared and there's some political expedience around getting something set up.
So we would go with that.
It would accommodate any possible census fluctuations.
It also is required to be, the whole model is around being home-like and normal so that children are, you know, feel like they're living a normal life and that encourages them to flourish.
There's a treatment milieu that emphasizes rehabilitation and really healthy child development.
So I know the chairman asked Thank you.
So I know the chairman asked for some details in money, like what would it cost to run these sort of things?
So we looked at two separate models right now.
Vermont is in the middle of building one.
And I know that you heard from Mr.
John DeJoy last week who gave you a copy of their proposal.
The Vermont is building a six bed facility.
And you can see that they've got, they're fairly heavy in management positions for that facility, six of them.
They have three clinical staff.
They have direct care workers, 28 of them, and direct care support.
And so their costs right now are the cost of operating for the year and also construction costs, which seems high, but it's still under what you're paying right now at the Sun Union Center.
On the left is Massachusetts.
They have a whole series of different sized group homes and different configurations.
They may be, many of them are operated by nonprofits.
It's under statute in New Hampshire that all residential programs that are contracted out must be contracted with nonprofit agencies.
And some of these are in state-owned facilities.
Some of them are owned by the nonprofit.
So I just chose this one just to give you a sense of the cost.
This is for 12 to 14 children.
They have a slightly fewer direct management staffing, 2.15 FTEs.
They have three clinical roles.
They have 20 direct care staffing.
And then their direct care support staffing would be like the maintenance and the cook.
And then they have some other funds that go into covering the cost of running the place.
These aren't entirely comparable to what you want to do because they don't, it's not clear where some items are covered.
And in particular, the Massachusetts model doesn't include education or health care.
The Vermont model does include a teacher.
So Massachusetts has a really interesting model and it works very well for them because of a Thank you.
model does include a teacher.
So Massachusetts has a really interesting model, and it works very well for them because of economy of scale, but they actually have an independent school, sort of without walls, that gives the state the ability to control the curriculum and make sure that teachers are licensed and adequately prepared.
And they embed teachers in all their group homes.
And that would work really well here, except for that we don't have as many group homes unless we expanded the service to some of the existing residential services.
It's really an interesting model, especially in New Hampshire where we're interested in charter schools to come up with a separate school without walls that serves folks.
And that kept some continuity of kids if they moved around.
And they also contract with a health care service regionally that provides health care to all of their group homes.
So those would still be issues we'd need to think about.
It's very difficult to calculate out the projected costs for New Hampshire.
Again, as I mentioned, their population is so small that it's very difficult to figure out how it would translate.
The second model that we propose as an alternative to incarceration and residential placement is the multi-dimensional treatment foster care.
This would actually complement the secure 12-bed facility.
It's a really interesting, very intensive therapeutic foster home that's designed specifically for adolescents who are delinquent or have emotional disturbances.
So the kids who would otherwise be incarcerated, depending upon their offenses and also depending upon their needs.
The foster parents receive exceptional training and support.
There's basically a wraparound with them.
The treatment in this model is both the child and the parents.
So stays range between five and 15 months at a cost of roughly about $25,000 to $35,000 per young person.
This also is very evidence-based and has really good outcomes.
There are exceptional rates as well for the foster parents.
I think in Massachusetts, they use a model like this.
They limit to two children per foster home.
But a lot of the young people that we see in the system, they don't do well in congregate settings.
Many of them, either because of their trauma or developmental conditions, have hypersensitivities to crowds, to noise, to textures and things.
And so many of them do much better in foster care.
But if you have foster parents who are really trained and prepared to take care of them and keep the community safe at the same time, it's a nice model.
So I know that when I spoke to you, Mr.
Chair, you were interested in the option of really cutting costs and closing the building and sending that money back to the taxpayer.
But all of the states that have gone through this sort of transformation, it's been very important that they have reserved the funds for the first few years and reinvested it to make sure that there's a system that's going to thoroughly support the transformation.
And I'll point out Connecticut, where they were really visibly making all sorts of plans and fighting hard to close their facility for over 20 years.
And then when they did close it, they just closed it and they didn't have a plan.
They moved all the money elsewhere and they have a lot of kids now in really very dire situation in detention facilities.
And so we really do not need to make that commitment.
So two sort of reinvestment funds that are important.
One is to enhance the system, to support the kids in these new models.
Intensive mentoring is absolutely critical.
It's also evidence-based that kids do better.
And that goes back to what I told you about.
One of the factors in kids recovering and their resilience is having a single care and consistent adult.
And I'll say I have members of my distant family who are now in their 60s, and they still do a lot of activities with their big brothers from when they were kids and they didn't have a dad.
And it's a beautiful relationship.
And they're all, you know, older men now who are retiring from really good careers and very civic minded.
So the idea of mentoring, it's an old school sort of thought, but it actually is very effective.
And it's really important that we invest.
We don't have enough mentors for kids now.
This fund would also, reinvestment fund would also have some flex funds for individualized tailored services, you know, for someone who might need specialized care and to be able to have that and get them through what they need to get through so that they'll completely recover and be able to be back out safely in the community.
And then along the idea of combining some of the initiatives that are underway right now, in the Senate Bill 94 that would do assessments of kids before they're petitioned for delinquency.
The assessment needs a place to happen.
And we've been sort of thinking the idea that it could happen at family resource centers because family resource centers are part of the community and they're normal.
It's not some institution that you have to go to.
It's not some police station that you have to go to.
But if we could somehow support them so that they could manage the plan is that the current juvenile probation and parole officers would conduct the assessments.
But if they had a nice, safe, comfortable place to do that, and also possibly think about moving diversion services into those family resource centers, we don't have consistent diversion services across the state.
Some municipalities have them.
Sometimes they're in police departments, sometimes they're in schools, but taking them out of the law enforcement emphasis and helping kids to feel a little bit more normal and welcoming to treatment might be a good place to go.
And it supports and upholds the, uplifts the family resource centers, which are really important resources.
And then finally, it's really important in New York state, in the previous Governor Cuomo, Mario Cuomo, famously walked into a 200 bed juvenile prison, and it was completely empty kids but it was fully staffed and he was very concerned about that in terms of how the state was spending the money but also was very concerned about what to do with the staff who were you know loyal state employees and so he created a fund to retrain redeploy all of the staff that had been at the facility.
So if you're building a smaller facility, obviously you're not going to need the 90 staff.
There are a lot of positions open right now on the child welfare side at DCYF.
There's going to be an enormous amount of positions that are opening up in all of the community-based treatment and support programs that are building up.
We just heard from a couple of people who are talking about workforce issues.
I came from Maine most recently, where when all of the paper mills closed down, a lot of people moved into healthcare roles and are liking them too.
So, you know, making sure that everyone has jobs, I think will be a good way for us to stay honoring the people who work for the state.
And then something that won't necessarily cost money, but is very important for this transition to happen is to create a multi-agency workgroup that will really focus on the transition and help make some of the decisions.
And it should include community and families.
We don't include families and the youth who experience juvenile justice themselves enough in these conversations.
We would suggest that we start right away by reviewing all the cases of the children at SYSC.
That's required in the law quarterly out of HB 517 from 2017.
And while it may be done, we think that bringing in a multi-agency group that may be able to think more creatively and know of other resources and may help push to get kids out of the Sununu Center safely and to achieve consensus on the model of this locked facility and what it's going to include and how we're going to pay for school and health care and to maintain momentum for this change.
the department has been dogged by the cost of the Sununu Center for many years, but it's very difficult to move forward when you also need to have a place for children and you have so many competing influences.
And then ultimately for this multi-agency group to monitor the implementation and quality outcomes of this change.
And the last couple of things to think about is accommodating gender.
If we're only going to have one small facility, which we do think could accommodate, like how do we accommodate boys, girls and transgender youngsters?
What do we do about overnight arrests when police pick someone up who's not safe to leave out in the street?
You know, does this facility have a wing or a cottage where people could be kept safe separately?
Do we mix detention and commitment?
They're so small, those two populations, it's hard to think about having more than one facility for each.
Geographical location is important.
We looked at where the kids are from.
Right now they're from all across the state.
Typically they tend to be from the southern end of the state.
And then finally, if you were going to have a new facility, thinking about what communities think about it, the not in my backyard influence is always a concern when you're trying to build these kinds of endeavors.
And finally, we do really need to think, and this necessarily isn't up to you, it's up to all of us to work with the department to seek other funding opportunities.
There is a Title II formula fund grant that comes from the Office of Juvenile Justice Delinquency Prevention, the federal OJJDP, that goes to the state advisory group.
We should revisit and reinvest that.
There's a lot of creative things you can do with that.
And I understand it's under new leadership and they are taking that under, but that's a resource that we don't want to lose and the OJJDP also has discretionary grants we could think about applying for that would support this transition.
So let's stop sharing.
So that's what I had to say quickly and if you have questions I'm happy to take them.
Thank you, Maura.
I don't know if there are questions because like I said, I can't really see everyone's hands.
I have questions.
I just wanted to make sure everyone had a chance to go before I do.
So if I were running a business, and this was a business, of business.
I think based on what you put together in a week from our talking, maybe 15 to 20 minutes, I would promote you and ask you to lead the project to take five or seven people and continue for the next two months to work on an 80-20 solution.
And that 80-20 solution would be with 20% of the normal time, come up with what you think an 80% solution looks like.
I like your framework.
I would like to know in the Vermont and Missouri models, Did they include options for the 14-year-old kid that killed his parents?
Thank you, Chairman, and thank you for the kind words.
Because I was trying to rush, I should have prefaced by saying that about two years ago, we were asked to lead a working group on juvenile justice.
It came out of a committee that was once again looking at what to do with this building that's happened a number of times.
And so we've been working with probably about 50 people throughout New Hampshire, government advocates everywhere.
So this isn't something that I necessarily pulled together myself, although I appreciate you thinking that.
We've also, in that process, made great connections nationally with really excellent consultants.
So we now have really good relationships around the country to get the information we need and make things happen.
The thinking around a level of offense is that New York City is now actually putting kids, if not in staff secure group homes, with very high offense levels.
all of those jurisdictions like New York City do have a higher level I think New York uses a state facility for kids who are extremely dangerous.
But for the most part, it depends upon that assessment that you do on a child to determine what is it that caused them to do such a bad thing.
And sometimes that can be mitigated.
It can be mitigated by medication.
It can be mitigated by removing them from an adverse situation.
It can be mitigated by many things.
So these models, when you go into the secure group home, the kids are mixed.
They're all the same.
And I would say from experience, the kids who have presented the most danger in the three years that I've been observing the Sununu Youth Services Center are the kids who have come in really mentally ill, like really sick, who really belonged either in a hospital or in a psychiatric residential treatment facility.
The kids who have committed terrible crimes since I've been here, if they're not mentally ill, they tend to be really some of the best kids to work with.
There's oftentimes, and you'll read in the research, there's oftentimes reason behind why they do the things they do.
And once that's resolved, they're much less dangerous to society.
And so those are the kids that we've seen finish school while they were at the Sununu Center, help out, not get in a lot of trouble.
So you can't determine how difficult it will be to care for a child based on their offense, because there's a lot of factors that feed into that.
But the way the Missouri model is built is that the staff is highly trained, and there's very deep supervision of the staff, and there's a low staff-to-child ratio so that they are able to manage the whole mix of the kids, unless it's someone who's really mentally ill and that's someone who would need acute psychiatric care.
Just to continue the conversation, the flip side of the coin on caring for the child that killed his or her parents is that there's a public safety concern, that there's just a public concern that their neighborhoods, their families are being protected by whatever the state action is.
So, as important as it is to look at the child's just assume you'd be, you'd appreciate that there's a balance there.
Yes.
Thank you for that opportunity to clarify that.
Absolutely.
A child who has committed a very serious offense like that would be in the secure facility.
You know, there's no doubt about that.
And then once you're there, they're doing the assessment and working with the child and sending them where they go.
So if you had a couple of months and you could bring in another five people, five to seven people, and do sort of a short version of a multi-agency study, do you think you could come up with something, a set of options that are really on the cusp of being actionable in terms of what the legislature does?
Sure, thank you, Chairman.
I think we absolutely could, but I do have to say that I run an agency with a very broad mandate with very little resources.
So it would be tough for us to focus just on that and get it done.
So we have a, we have a number of large, you know, projects and investigations that we have to give attention to.
I mean, if it were possible to have a few dollars to hire a consultant to coordinate that sort of a project, I think it would be doable.
But it's hard for me to, you know, overextend my agency and not be able to meet our mandate in other ways.
I appreciate that.
So how quickly could you hire a consultant and how much money would you need for a two-month project?
Off the top's, that's the top of your head.
Yeah.
I'm terrible with numbers.
It's why I'm not on the finance committee.
You know, I would, I would, I, you know, I, I couldn't even guess it.
I can get that information for you.
Yeah.
Think about that.
I really, I think we have, as I understand the budget process, we, we finish our work on the 24th.
It goes to Senate.
Senate works on it for a month or two.
And then it goes to a committee of conference.
So if there was an expeditious way to really try to come up with something, I think maybe at the back end of this and the committee you know, maybe we could do something actionable.
Sure, sure.
I'd be happy to, you know, send some feelers out.
I actually have a meeting tomorrow with folks who have been great resource to us from Columbia University and so and I'm sure they're well connected enough to give me a sense of who's available for that kind of work and what it would cost.
And I just also want to let you know I appreciated your concerns about the existing personnel at the Sununu Center.
And I would just say that in all of these presentations, we continuously hear the theme that there are vacancies.
And so I would really hope that there would be a redeployment retraining opportunity there that would be part of it.
And since you put it in your slide deck, I think that would come out of an 80-20 plan.
Yeah, thank you.
I think that's really important.
I think it's important to be respectful of them.
And it has been hard for them because not only do people talk about closing the facility, but it's often in the news as though it's a terrible place.
And we know that there's a lawsuit right now and a criminal investigation.
And I do want to emphasize that our discussion today about looking for an alternative transition for this facility has nothing to do with those things.
It has everything to do with what the science tells us works, what makes a community safer, and what would start to save New Hampshire some money.
So far, I've been asking you questions.
I haven't asked you to do any work other than to be able to answer the question.
Other than to solve the problem.
Yeah, solve the problem.
That's all I'm asking.
So, so I, again, I just really want to thank you.
I mean, you and I had never met.
We talked for 15 to 20 minutes on the phone.
Thank you, Representative Wollner for introducing us.
And I really, I appreciate what you put together.
I think it was, it was very, very tight.
Very good.
Great.
Thank you.
We're happy to help.
Any other questions I'm happy to answer?
Otherwise, I'll thank you for your time.
I'd just like to say thank you for joining us, Mara.
It was a great presentation.
Thank you.
This is lots of things to think about.
And please, I'll get back to the committee when I have more information about the consultant and a plan around that.
But if any of you have questions in the meantime, please don't hesitate to reach out.
Mr.
Chair, I think that's the end of the three people that Kathy and Sharon and I invited.
All right.
Well, thank you.
Well done.
It's almost like you've been a chairman before.
I tried once before.
So is Representative Cody Belanger in the audience?
Because I think he had thought he was going to speak in conjunction with Maura.
Don't touch anything.
Do you see Cody Belanger?
I don't see that name.
All right.
So why don't you bring in Jim Moynihan and Chuck Nickerson both and we'll start a conversation.
Okay, I see Jim.
And it looks like Chuck is there.
So you guys can both take your mics off of mute.
Okay, Mr.
Nickerson, it's good seeing you again, sir.
Good seeing you to be representative Edwards.
Okay, now both you and Mr.
Moynihan are going to talk about the related topic.
I don't know if you've done any coordination of your presentation between the two of you.
We have actually, and I'd like to, if you could bring in Ray Bauer, who's the long-term care administrator and also the county administrator for Stratford County as well.
He'll help present the county's point of view.
Okay, I see someone in the audience just named Ray.
I'm going to assume that's who it is.
Yes.
Good to see you, Chuck.
Hey, good to see you too, Representative Weiler.
So do you just want me to lead off Representative Edwards?
Please.
Okay.
So as you may or may not know, I think you probably do from probably talking to other members of your committee and also Representative Weiler.
A main concern of the counties is the governor's proposed budget as it pertains to the county cap.
So normally there would be about a three percent annual increase in the county cap and in what's called for in the governor's budget is actually an 18 percent increase.
Now just to kind of correlate correlate, you know, what does a 3% versus 18% increase mean?
With a 3% based upon the SFY 2021 cap, that's about $3.7 million increase to all 10 counties in total for the net cap.
If an 18% increase means an increase of about $22 million, not 3.7, but $22 million to the counties.
And because that increase is happening all in the first year, you also have a cumulative second year increase as well overall for the two-year period basically it comes to an amount about 33 million dollars over two years that normally the counties would be worrying about now say like seven and a half to eight million maybe at most for an increase the counties are worried about now about 24 25 million dollars higher than anticipated or actually sorry 33 million dollars higher over two years anticipated than a normal two-year budget and in turn that's going to lead to a tax increase for Rockham County I can say it's going to be 7.2 percent.
I believe Ray from Stratford confirmed too for Stratford County it's about a 7% tax increase.
And there's not really, you know, revenues coming in per se.
I mean, yes, we have some as a result from MQIP as a result of and spent monies, you know, in 504.
But...
So put in perspective for us that 7 percent, that's 7 percent at the county level.
What would that be?
So would it feel like to a typical Rockingham County property taxpayer?
Well, it depends what town you're from.
If you're from Portsmouth, you could be looking at county taxes make up, you know, five percent, five, six percent of your tax bill.
It seems like mostly the donor town tax, you know, taxpayers would feel more of that impact versus, you know, some other town that's not a donor town, whether, you know, say Derry, Lunderry, something like that.
So your people that are from, say, Newington, Newcastle, Portsmouth, Rye, they're the ones who are going to feel more so this increase.
So I can't like give you, you know, it's going to seem one way to, you know, when, you know, all county taxpayers for Rockingham or from other counties as well.
But at the end of it, it would be a perceptible increase in their property taxes i mean i would think so especially if you're a commercial taxpayer as far as commercial property owner um obviously the towns especially see it uh because they're the ones who actually directly pay the counties so they would especially see it i could easily picture a city of Portsmouth calling, you know, like right away once they were seeing, you know, once they were hearing the amount of what would be approved for taxes by the Rockham County delegation.
If this was not to change.
Now, obviously, from the governor's last proposed budget, it was a 9% increase.
So we're used to seeing a much larger increase, and then it settles down at about a 3% past increase.
So we know this is only the starting point.
So, but this is the largest increase I've seen in my, you know, 12 years here at the county.
I'm sure Ray will probably confirm it's the highest one he's seen.
That's been in the governor's proposed budget for his time.
But, but again, you know, 7% tax increase.
Again, normally, you know, Rockham County alone would be seeing a 3.7 million increase in taxes.
And that's the norm for all 10 counties seeing in one fiscal year for a cap increase so it's it's definitely something that we're concerned about but again we realize it's only the starting point and uh and we do have some other topics that that kind of feed off of that And I guess for some of the other items, I'll hand it off to Ray.
So Ray, if you can unmute yourself.
Thank you.
My name is Ray Bauer.
For whatever reason, my video isn't picking up, but my name is Ray Bauer.'ve been the county administrator and a nursing home administrator in Stratford County for 32 years and just to finish off one point that Chuck made.
This is the highest starting point we've ever seen in the governor's proposed budget in terms of the county cap since there's been a county cap.
However many years that goes back.
A couple of the other things that concern us in relation to the way the budget's proposed is the bed count.
This is based on 4,100 projected Medicaid residents.
And...
And I can assure you, although the state isn't sharing with us the exact average bed count, the last update was in the public dashboard is November of 2019.
I can assure you it's nowhere near 4,100 beds.
Just between the vacant beds due to COVID, between Rockingham, Stratford, Hillsborough, and Merrimack, it's not even 3,700 beds.
So one of the things that we were working or hoping for an adjustment on is that the bed count at 4,100 is much too high.
And obviously, the cost is a product of the bed count times the average Medicaid reimbursement rate equals the total amount of money that's appropriated.
So, but to give you a clearer example of that, in January, there was every January and every July, there's a rate adjustment.
The rate adjustment for or in January, the state used a bed count of 3,791 Medicaid residents.
And as you know, COVID has continued to be problematic, certainly between January and now, and certainly into the rest of the year.
So the fact that the state used 3791 in January, but is proposing 4,100 for July, just on its face doesn't seem correct.
May I ask you a question there?
Certainly.
Yeah, so I've not played with this cost management formula that you're so familiar with?
Am I right to assume that if the bed count assumption declines quite a bit, that that in effect reduces the amount of money that the counties would be projected to expend?
Absolutely, sir.
You're absolutely correct, Representative Edwards.
Okay.
So what's bad about planning 4,100, having it really be 3,700?
Your budget would be planned to be higher than the reality.
So that wouldn't be a great plan, but what's the worst part of doing it that way?
Well, that's a main contributor to the proposed increase for the county taxpayers is that we're being our county taxpayers are being assessed for based on a number that doesn't exist and that money would then be you know have to be appropriated for beds that we know won't be filled and that's again a large contributor to the numbers that Chuck Nickerson brought up.
So Mr.
Nickerson mentioned under the current budget, there's an 18% increase in the governor's budget.
if if the planning number were reduced to 3,700, did you happen to figure out what kind of percentage increase we'd be talking about in that scenario?
I can only presume that's 10% reduction.
I can presume it's 10% off the top for what the governor's proposed.
Okay, so we'd still be talking about 15%, 16% instead of 18%.
Well, you'd still be talking probably 8% or 10% as opposed to the 18% if we reduced it you know 10.
Yes.
All right so so the takeaway from there for me is it's just really important to get the state and the county to come up with a good agreed upon bed count estimate for the future.
That would be wonderful.
Any any pressure that this committee could exert on the state to give us an average bed count for the last year or month by month, which used to be published on their dashboard, that would be really helpful in us entertaining a meaningful negotiation with the state about that line item.
the state about that line item.
So we're not here to pressure the executive branch.
We're here to work with them collaboratively.
Sorry, Representative Edwards.
Bad choice of words on my part.
All right.
Keep going.
The other thing that might end up with legislation, and we hope it doesn't, is that the counties right now, by statute, share the obligation with the federal government of paying for long-term care Medicaid at 50 and 50.
So we pay half, they pay half.
One, one issue is that the federal government increased their contribution from 50% to 56.2%.
And, but the counties have received no benefit by having their share reduced when the federal share went up.
And we've been trying to work with the state to agree on the mathematical formula to make that equitable.
So if the counties pay for the half that the federal government doesn't pay for, and the federal government wants to pay more than half, we believe, as we have in the past, that the federal government doesn't pay for and the federal government wants to pay more than half, we believe as we have in the past that the counties should receive that reduction.
That's about 15 million dollars a year spread out over the 10 counties.
To date, even though we've made efforts to work with DHHS to come up with an equitable solution, that hasn't occurred.
And we just wanted to bring that to the attention of the committee because it might end up needing to be resolved legislatively.
And we hope it doesn't.
Okay, so in the coming budget, how far into the budget do you think will go before the federal government may reduce that 56% back to 50%?
It's 90 days after the pandemic is stopped.
That's what the current law says.
So it continues until the federal government says there's no pandemic any longer, and then it goes 90 days beyond that.
But the other thing is it goes backwards also to when the pandemic began.
So we're actually talking about a portion into the last fiscal year and all of this fiscal year.
So right now, we're probably talking $20 million that's in question between the state and the counties.
And every month it continues to go up.
I don't have a good vision as to when the federal government believes that the pandemic will be over.
But I have every confidence that it's, you know, going to last for the balance of this year.
So every, again, every month that goes by, you know, it's another one and a quarter million dollars.
Representative Irf, you have a question?
I do.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
So, Ray, I have a question.
First of all, I'll give you some background about what I've heard, what I understand from the state.
One of the statements I believe they make is that that enhanced FNAP is intended to account for the fact that they can no longer, the discharge is the wrong word, but they have to keep people on Medicaid, I guess, that no longer qualify.
And a question I've asked them, which I've not been able to get an answer to, is do you know who those people are?
I don't mean the names, but I mean the population.
Are those people in nursing homes?
Are those people in, you know, what situations are those people in that supposedly are the reason for the enhanced F-MAP?
They're not in nursing homes.
They're not part of the people that we're responsible for.
At all?
At all.
When we've asked the state, why are you keeping that $6.2 million, it was said to us at the beginning that, or I'm sorry, 6.2%, that it's used to offset other Medicaid costs, but it falls outside of any of the county's responsibilities.
Now, our discussions have continued since then.
I'm not sure that that still continues to be their point.
But we, again, we're trying to resolve this non-legislatively.
And we're trying to resolve this through direct contact with DHHS.
And when you say it doesn't include any of the people the county is responsible for, are you including the other lines in this calculation, the mid-level care expenses, the home support waiver services, and the home health care waiver services?
As far as I know, yes, sir, absolutely.
The state has never brought it to our attention at all that this, in fact, kind of it's the first time that I've heard this.
But they've never brought it to our attention that any of those people are included in that dilemma that they have.
Okay, can you guess who those people are?
I don't know, sir.
As you know, the Medicaid system is very expansive, especially with all the changes that have been made in Medicaid system in the last few years.
So I know as an example, because our county of a population of 120,000 has 20,000 people on Medicaid.
So I, and only a fraction of those people are in our part of what the county is responsible for, a small fraction of those people.
So my, you know, I can only presume it's somewhere of the 21,500 extra people that aren't currently the county's responsibility.
I thank you for your answers.
Are there any other questions while we're kind of taking questions?
I'm not seeing any.
Do you remember where you left off?
Yes, I just have one last point and I know it's been a long day for you so I'll make it very quickly.
For all of the time that all of you have spent on your county delegation, I know that you're well familiar with a system of drawdown from the federal government called ProShare that all the counties benefit from.
It matches what the nursing homes are reimbursed compared to what the federal Medicare upper limit is.
And that's been guaranteed to us as a relatively constant source of revenue.
However, we've been notified that that's likely to get down precipitously.
The state is calculating that information to us, and that will affect every county.
So we just wanted to take this opportunity to let you know that it makes that large proposed increase by the governor even more difficult to swallow when we're potentially losing a good portion of our revenue stream.
Okay.
So can you quantify that pro-share impact at all?
I don't recall hearing a number.
Our Shrafford County gets about $6.1 million in pro share.
We're supposed to have calculations by the end of this week about what the new pro share distribution amount is.
It's scheduled in the state budget to be a gross number of $71 million distributed to all 10 counties.
I couldn't even get a guesstimate from your director of Medicaid, from Henry, and he's been trying very hard to get us that number, but he won't have that number, he says, till the end of this week.
But from every indication we've had, that it could go down as much as 50% or more.
Okay, so I have a different kind of question for you.
It's kind of organizational slash communication.
How is it that the 10 counties communicate to DHHS on these issues?
Is there an organization on behalf of the counties that serves point to talk to somebody at DHHS or is it every county for themselves?
No, it's absolutely coordinated through Jim Monahan and the DuPont group.
We'll communicate with Lori Shibonett, your commissioner, and we and Jim will pick experts from respective counties.
All counties are involved and all counties have been consulted with the positions that we've been putting forward today.
And we try and consolidate the input to your respective legislative committees to keep it short.
And the last thing you want is 10 people, one from each county saying the exact same thing.
Okay, are there any other questions for Mr.
Bowers or Mr.
Nickerson?
I'm not seeing any.
Do either of you have kind of final thought now that we've talked through that?
Cause I'm about to bring Mr.
Moynihan in.
I just wanted to thank you for your time and and and your willingness to listen to our plight.
Well it's not just you obviously right I mean we're in effect listening to our every property taxpayer in New Hampshire.
Yes sir.
You're presenting a picture where, you know, if we don't talk to one another, we're going to accidentally cause a huge property tax or at least a significant property tax increase for everyone in the state.
So I'm pretty sure that nobody wants to be raising taxes right now coming out of a pandemic.
So Representative Edwards, it was a question that you asked Mr.
Nickerson, but maybe it's because I've been around way too long.
I would estimate for an average Stratford County taxpayer, that increase would be three to $400 on their tax bill annually.
So that's real money.
I mean, if I had to write another $400 check, I'd notice it.
That would be for the average taxpayer.
You know, when you multiply that for business taxes and things, I think you'd see a more substantial increase.
For Stratford County, about 10% of the average tax bill is related to county expenses.
That's simply a product of the equalized assessed evaluation.
And if you take an average home, they pay about $400, between $400 and $500.
When you multiply that by the 8%, you're you're talking about four hundred dollars okay thank you thank you so much uh mr monahan do you do you want to go off of uh mute and there you are good afternoon you have prepared uh like a thought in mind that you came prepared to share with us or you know not necessarily I think we want to make sure the county officials spoke directly to the committee so I think Chuck and Ray did a really good job of that I should just add a couple of observations you asked about organized communications with the department.
We do have a county state finance commission that meets at least quarterly, if not more frequently, for that level of engagement.
And Representative Weiler is a legislative representative to that committee.
So that's kind of on top of the association effort that Ray talked about.
I think that our goal know, our goal on this page of the budget, I guess, is to try to work cooperatively with the department to bring you all a solution so that we don't have the steep increase in county property tax rates, but at the same time, try to fund the long-term care structure.
So I think, you know, as it's been identified here, I think the pieces to that are getting a good bed count, funding to that, and then finding the right balance between the county and state contribution.
I suspect over the next few days, we could probably have a more precise straw proposal for you to look at for both House Bill 1 and House Bill 2, if that's something you'd like us to work on.
Absolutely.
I mean, I don't know if you know our internal timeline, but Division 3, we have to be finished with what our work is on the DHHS budget on the 24th of March.
So if we get something earlier than that and give us some time to internalize it and soak it a little bit that would be helpful then that our contribution goes to the finance committee where chairman weiler will integrate everything i've never seen that but i i just know my panic date is the 24th.
Okay.
Yeah, no, we can work with you on that.
I mean, I think is was identified, you know, there are some tricky components here and, you know, folks like Karen rounds and Henry Lippman have worked very well with us and we, you know, particularly around the pro share piece so we don't lose any federal dollars.
I mean, that's a big goal, I think, all around.
So there is some complexity to it.
Okay, are there any questions for Mr.
Moynihan?
Let's go out and look at the attendees.
Do the attendees have a question or a short refinement, of something that has been said.
This isn't, we're not trying to create a debate society.
We're just trying to get things exposed.
I'm not seeing anyone, are you, Mr.
Ripple, on the attendees?
I'm not.
Okay.
Well, all right.
So I think that does it.
Have I forgotten somebody that I wanted to have to speak?
I don't think I have.
I think you covered everybody on the email that you sent out.
OK, good.
All right, well, I think that closes down the guest star portion of today's presentations.
And wait, we have Representative Nordgren.
Question?
No, thank you.
I just wanted to thank you for your consideration in letting us bring in these people.
I think you should be a model for some of the other committees.
So I just wanted to thank you.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
All right.
So I'll put that in an endless loop on my campaign page, if you don't mind.
But on a serious note, I don't see any other questions.
So we're finished with the guest portion of this.
And so let's just go back to a committee as a whole, or a division three, and Mr.
Ripple, the next time we meet, I think, is at noon on Friday.
Is that a true statement?
That's correct.
And the goal from noon to 2.30 on Friday is for us to take our first break and brush through HB 2.
And Representative Walner has nominated a topic that has been emailed to everyone.
We'll start with hers.
But the point of this is I think my objective is to have us touch every HB2 item that has come over in the budget proposal and make sure we know if we're comfortable with it as is or if we think that there may be something that needs to be tweaked.
I know there's been a few suggestions on some others.
I'll get organized so that we hit those.
But, but so I think we'll need all of the two and a half hours on Friday for HB2 is my guess and maybe more.
Any comment on that?
Your hand is still up, Representative Norgood.
okay all.
Well, last call.
I'm not seeing any.
So with that, I think we're adjourned.
So I appreciate everyone's time today.
Thank you.